bonjour à tous
mesdames Messieurs mes chers collègues
chers président Artano cher Stéphane je
salue évidemment tout particulièrement
nos amis d'outre-mer qui sont en lien
vidéo on vous voit bien est-ce que vous
nous entendez correctement et évidemment
vous nous ferez parfait bonjour à tous
merci de votre présence lointaine mais
sympathique ce matin pour nous
bonjour à tous évidemment nous sommes
très heureux de l'organisation
conjointe de ces tables rondes qui nous
permettent aujourd'hui de prendre le
temps de traiter un thème insuffisamment
abordé et pourtant crucial pour
l'entrepreneuriat en outre-mer
en effet le défi de l'emploi local est
extrêmement important beaucoup de
territoires ils sont confrontés mais la
situation spécifique de l'outre-mer
mérité que l'on s'y attarde pour
identifier les obstacles au retour des
jeunes diplômés dans leur territoire
est-ce un problème d'inadéquation des
emplois et compétences recherchées avec
les qualifications de ces jeunes des
initiatives entrepreneuriales
peuvent-elles être une solution mais
quelles sont les difficultés rencontrées
par ceux qui tentent de créer leurs
entreprises ces questions sont
évidemment fondamentales et font écho
aux travaux en cours de la délégation
aux entreprises sur les thèmes de la
formation des compétences et de
l'attractivité des métiers et des
entreprises évidemment heureux que nos
deux délégations chers présidents
travaillent de concert sur ce sujet
Michel Calvet présence matin chers
collègues et d'ailleurs l'un des
rapporteurs de la mission d'information
avec Martine Berthet et Florence blatrix
compta sur le thème de la formation des
compétences ce serait heureux le
présider la seconde table ronde de ce
matin qui permettra de valoriser
différentes initiatives privées
montrant la dynamique des chefs
d'entreprise en outre-mer c'est cette
approche pratique de terrain qui nourrit
les travaux de la délégation
d'entreprise depuis plus de 8 ans je
rappelle que nous sommes une instance
unique au sein du Parlement ayant pour
mission de recenser les obstacles au
développement des entreprises et de
proposer des mesures visant à simplifier
les normes applicables à l'activité
économique en vue d'encourager la
croissance et l'emploi dans les
territoires l'imaginer qu'à tel projet
va nous prendre pas mal d'énergie le
dialogue avec l'échelle d'entreprise
lors de visite de terrain constitue
l'ADN de la délégation a déjà rencontré
environ 2000 dirigeants au cours de la
quarantaine de déplacements effectués
dans différents départements et les
éditions de la journée des entreprises
d'organiser au Sénat
nous comptons au sein de la délégation
des membres très impliqués et passionnés
dont vous faites partie chers Stéphane
Artano je vous remercie d'avoir fait le
pari de cet événement commun pour cette
problématique qui nous intéresse tant je
remercie de nouveau évidemment tous les
participants de ce matin et chers
Président je vous passe la parole
merci monsieur le Président cher Serge
chers collègues mesdames messieurs je
remercie évidemment Serge pour
l'organisation conjoint de cette table
ronde qui vient de le dire afin
d'aborder la question du recrutement
pour les entreprises du tramarine et
l'attractivité des emplois dans cet
territoire cette collaboration s'inscrit
d'ailleurs pleinement dans l'esprit et
les conclusions du rapport gruni en
faveur de plus de travaux conjoints au
sein de notre assemblée et de ses
différentes instances enfin la vocation
de la délégation outre-mer et de
diffuser la culture ultramarine auprès
de tous nos collègues nous avons
souhaité retenir ce thème pour plusieurs
raisons tout d'abord les travaux notre
délégation pointe de manière régulière
et forte le défaut structurel
d'ingénierie aussi bien administratif
organisationnel technique ou financière
dans nos territoires
cela vaut pour les organismes publics
comme pour les entreprises tous les
domaines sont concernés faire venir ou
retenir les talons et difficiles cette
facteur clé qui opère et retarde la
réalisation des projets les outre-mer
fourmis de projets mais ils peinent
souvent à sortir de terre par ailleurs
la situation démographique est
inquiétante sur plusieurs de nos
territoires les Antilles nouvelles
Calédonie Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon sont
des prises démographiques ces
territoires se vident de leur jeunesse
inversement la Guyane ou Mayotte
connaissent un boom démographique chez
les moins de 25 ans mais ne parviennent
pas à attirer les jeunes actifs
créateurs de richesse
les récents travaux de nos collègues
Catherine Concorde et Guillaume
chevrolier sur la continuité
territoriale ont mis l'accent sur la
question du retour au pays la réforme de
la Dom encore préparation devrait mettre
l'accent sur cette nouvelle dimension je
citerai aussi la recommandation numéro
10 du rapport de nos collègues qui
propose de mettre la Dom au service des
projets de territoire définis par les
collectivités ultramarines ces projets
de territoire concerneraient
naturellement la question des métiers en
tension ou l'accompagnement des
étudiants ultramarins dont leur projet
poste études enfin pour faire écho
leitmotiv du ministre chargé des
Outre-mer la création de valeur doit
être la priorité des politiques
publiques pour répondre à
l'insatisfaction de nos concitoyens
ultramarins or cette création de valeur
ne pourra se faire sont les femmes et
des hommes dotés de compétences et de
qualifications nécessaires
pour cette première table ronde nous
aurons le plaisir d'entendre
successivement madame Sophie Broca
directrice générale des Outre-mer des OM
vous êtes au cœur de la machine
d'interministérielle et la question de
l'attractivité des territoires est au
cœur des arbitrages en cours
en prévision du prochain comité
interministériel des autres mères
annoncée le 12 juin madame Isabelle
Richard sous directrice des politiques
publiques vous accompagne ensuite
Monsieur Didier fauchard vice-président
de la Fédération des Entreprises
d'outre-mer fait Dom président du
Mouvement des Entreprises de France
réunion Medef réunion ou vous ouvrez
l'écho des difficultés que les
entreprises ultramarines vous remontent
pour recruter les talents et les
personnes qualifiées nécessaires à leur
développement votre expérience
réunionnaise sera évidemment très
intéressante monsieur Yannick Lortie
professeur de sciences économiques à
l'université Gustave Eiffel auteur
d'études sur la discrimination à
l'embauche des jeunes ultramarins vous
nous direz si ces discriminations ou des
barrières à l'embauche existent
également dans les territoires romarin
en particulier les territoires d'origine
des jeunes diplômés peut-être
pourrez-vous nous donner des pistes sur
la manière de désamorcer ces barrières
enfin Madame Cynthia renaissa que je
salue en visioconférence cofondatrice de
l'association Guyane en vol votre
association madame a développé des
dispositifs de parrainage et
d'accompagnement des jeunes ultramarins
vers les études supérieures on retourne
se pose évidemment la question de la
suite du parcours de ces jeunes comment
envisage-t-il le début de leur vie
professionnelle au pays ou ailleurs vous
nous ferait part de votre expérience je
vous remercie aussi pour votre
mobilisation compte tenu de l'horaire
très matinal en Guyane je vous céderai
tout d'abord la parole pour un propos
liminaire d'une durée de 7 minutes
maximum car la table ronde est joint de
suivre par avance mais je suis aussi un
peu Gardiens du Temps de cette première
table ronde devra ne se terminer
impérativement à 10h30 mes collègues
vous poseront ensuite des questions pour
favoriser les échanges je vous propose
de passer dans l'ordre que j'ai que j'ai
indiqué en commençant par Madame madame
Sophie Broca ou madame Richard
mais sur les présidents mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames
messieurs d'abord permettez-moi de vous
remercier pour cette initiative
conjointe qui est féconde parce que je
pense que les regards croisés ne peuvent
que nous enrichir et la présence ici à
la fois de praticien et de et de
praticiens de porteurs de projets et de
d'académie
est une bonne chose ensuite vous dire
que je devrais partir à 10h45 parce que
j'ai un rendez-vous chez incontournable
sur la Nouvelle-Calédonie voilà donc
pour bien comprendre la règle du jeu
monsieur le Président là je parle 7
minutes et j'arrête c'est ça la question
un premier tour de table en 7 minutes et
puis les collègues poseront les
questions par la suite pour avoir une
interaction ok alors
nous vu de notre porte qui est celle
d'une administration interministérielle
qui est chargé de faire des plaidoyer en
quelque sorte sur les outre-mer pour
essayer de faire infuser comme vous le
faites à votre mesure aussi ici à faire
infuser le réflexe et la sensibilité
ultra-marine dans les différentes
administrations parce que non ce qui est
conçu pour pour l'Aveyron ou pour le
Finistère n'est pas forcément totalement
adapté toujours ça peut être mais pas
toujours
aux
outre-mer du point de vue enfin vu de
notre porte sur le plan économique il
nous semble au fond que ces territoires
ultramarins sont dans un huis clos
économique un huis clos je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail puisque le temps
imparti ne le permet pas mais je
pourrais répondre un huis clos qui du
coup freine le développement économique
évidemment
c'est péjoratif pour la croissance d'un
territoire et pour le bien-être des
populations dans ce cas les raisons de
ce huis clos sont multiples il y a
d'abord le huis clos de ces territoires
avec la océans c'est un fait physique un
dépassable
pour lequel on ne peut rien même avec du
coup des marchés étroits dans lesquels
on a des difficultés à faire émerger des
des modèles compétitifs avec des
économies d'échelle mais il y a des
solutions il y a toujours des solutions
on peut penser à la connectivité on peut
penser vous l'avez dit Monsieur artanou
à la politique de continuité
territoriale qui est en effet en cours
de réforme et qu'il doit mieux prendre
en compte ces aspects là on peut penser
à une réforme de la de l'aide aux
frettes qui n'est pas de notre point de
vue suffisamment efficace mais c'est un
huis clos aussi je le dis avec mes mots
qui est lié aussi à l'histoire coloniale
depuis l'histoire coloniale c'est le
territoire se sont construits avec des
entreprises dominantes avec des
entreprises dominantes qui sont des
entreprises de main d'oeuvre pour la
plupart du temps alors que les
territoires ont besoin de monter en
qualification pour pour les aider à se
structurer
des entreprises dominantes ces
entreprises de main d'oeuvre elles ont
enfin c'est difficile pour les
entreprises concurrentes matures
d'exister et de percer sur sur les
marchés
c'est donc une difficulté il y a
d'autres plafonds de verre qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à dépasser par des
accompagnements adaptés l'économie
informelle la difficulté du passage de
zéro salarié ce qui est la plupart face
qui est le cas de la plupart des
entreprises
ultramarines à un salarié la question de
la sous de l'insuffisance des fonds
propres qui créent un cercle vicieux pas
de enfin dette sociale et fiscale donc
pas accès auprès pas accès aux aides
publiques voilà il y a aussi un huis
clos des entreprises avec une fiscalité
locale qui n'est pas toujours très
transparente qui est assez complexe et
qui n'est pas stable ce qui peut créer
de l'incertitude là aussi le ministre
la vidéo d'outre-mer souhaite engager
avec les acteurs économiques avec les
collectivités et les et les ministres
concernés une réflexion pour une
fiscalité plus transparente plus
cohérente plus protectrice du pouvoir
d'achat sans porter atteinte
naturellement aux ressources des
collectivités territoriales puisque
l'octroi de mer historiquement est une
taxe qui a été créée pour offrir un
certain rendement aux collectivités
locales il y a un huis clos aussi dans
la relation un peu univoque et trop
exclusive entre ces territoires
ultramarins et la métropole
l'essentiel du commerce de l'importation
des des relations commerciales se
passent avec avec l'Hexagone là aussi
nous avons engagé des mesures vint des
travaux notamment avec l'Union
européenne pour créer un marquage RUP
région
ultra périphérique qui permettrait
aux territoires ultramarins de commercer
avec leurs voisins et d'acheter par
exemple le travail est engagé pour les
matériaux de construction d'acheter pour
contourner à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
plutôt au Canada les matériaux qui vont
permettre de construire un lycée
où d'autres équipements et donc de
plutôt que d'avoir un faire
venir tout ça de métropole avec les
coûts et les surcoûts que ça que ça
suppose et donc cette initiative il
faudrait qu'on puisse les tendre à
d'autres secteurs il y a aussi toute la
diplomatie économique sans doute qu'il
faut mieux mieux mieux porter mieux
développer dans le cas des conférences
régionales par bassin qui réunissent
tous les tous les états des différentes
zones il y a le soutien avec de l'export
avec business France que nous que nous
finançons enfin je passerai vite il y a
aussi un huis clos sans doute avec un
modèle économique qui qui doit être
pensé différemment pour l'avenir qui
doit être pensé de manière durable je
voudrais juste insister sur le fait que
les territoires ultramarins situés dans
la bande intertropicale seront les
premiers les plus violemment touchés par
le changement climatique qu'il est
impératif que cette
réflexion soit portée par tous les
acteurs l'État les collectivités la
société civile et les entreprises il
faut anticiper ce changement climatique
qui aura un impact fort sur les modes de
vie l'alimentation l'habitat etc sur la
question assurantielle pour les
entreprises qui va être très importantes
et je pense que à cette occasion il peut
y avoir une réflexion pour réduire
pour réduire la dépendance à l'import
pour rééquilibrer la balance commerciale
avec une réflexion autour de la
diversification du modèle économique
pour moi dépendre d'un ou deux domaines
ce secteur dominant voilà je passe je
passe je ne détaille pas parce que je
crois que le temps ne me le permet pas
mais je reviendrai naturellement en
fonction de vos questions sur ces
différents points sur l'ensemble des
aides aujourd'hui mobilisées par l'État
pour aider les entreprises à exister à
se développer ça va évidemment des aides
fiscales au subventions à l'aide à la
bancarisation avec le soutien d'un
certain nombre d'opérateurs
et j'aborde très rapidement le dernier
point qui est aussi au centre de vos
préoccupations c'est la question des
compétences et des qualifications des
entreprises même si elles arrivent à
exister à se développer avant un modèle
économique à être dans un rapport plus
compétitif avec leur marché ont besoin
de talons et vous l'avez dit c'est un
problème les talons soit il ne reste pas
enfin faire leurs études ailleurs ils ne
reviennent pas soit ce qui reste peuvent
parfois être dans des difficultés
d'accès à la formation bon il y a
d'abord un problème qu'il faut pas
méconnaître et qui est réel c'est le
taux d'illettrisme et d'électronisme qui
est très important qui est un taux du
double quadruple par rapport à la
métropole difficile d'apprendre dans ces
conditions là il faut que les pouvoirs
publics est une action plus volontariste
et le ministre est en train de réfléchir
en lien avec l'ampli à des actions je
pense que il y a aussi besoin besoin de
que les régions s'emparent d'une GPEC
qu'avec les acteurs économiques c'est la
compétence des régions la formation
professionnelle la carte des formations
je pense qu'avec les entreprises il faut
que ils imaginent les métiers de demain
les compétences de demain il faut y
penser maintenant pour que les
formations se mettent en place et que
le les formations se mettent en place il
faut du temps donc il faut anticiper
penser au métier demain et penser aux
métiers que les jeunes ont envie de
faire voilà on peut pas juste dire à un
jeune bah c'est très bien la Martinique
et la Guadeloupe la Martinique sera le
département le plus vieux de France et
donc tu vas t'occuper des seniors et du
grand âge c'est pas forcément comme ça
qu'on attire des jeunes et donc il y a
aussi une réflexion à conduire là dessus
le préfet de Guadeloupe a fait
l'exercice je pourrais revenir si vous
le voulez
plus tard
je pense que les entreprises ont aussi
des responsabilités l'état des
responsabilités lutter contre
l'électricité l'électronisme et des
régions à faire ce travail de GPEC
anticiper les besoins je pense que les
entreprises ont aussi des
responsabilités qui leur sont propres
qu'il faut publier les offres de stage
de les offres de stage d'apprentissage
les offres d'emploi sur une plateforme
unique c'est un débat qu'on a eu déjà
avec la FEDOM il n'y a pas d'offre de
stage
ultramarine accessible en vous êtes en
métropole vous voulez faire un stage il
y a aucune visibilité il y a pas un lieu
où vous trouvez toutes les offres de
stage tous les offres d'apprentissage
donc je pense que là il faut que les
entreprises s'impliquent davantage pour
grouper leurs offres que il faut qu'elle
puisse attirer des jeunes stagiaires et
les fidéliser via
le stage de fin d'études via du mentorat
pour que ces jeunes stagiaires ces
jeunes talents et envie de rester dans
l'entreprise il faut bien sûr renforcer
l'apprentissage mais le gouvernement
travaille à des annonces là-dessus
voilà être et puis peut-être que les
entreprises peuvent prendre davantage de
risques en offrant des postes en jeu
qu'on offrirait pas en métropole à
quelqu'un qui a tel âge et telle
formation et tel parcours peut-être
qu'il faut attirer les jeunes aussi en
leur offrant et parcours de carrière pas
forcément pour la vie on peut imaginer
qu'un jeune retourne un jeune ingénieur
retournant outre-mer pour une étape de
sa vie professionnelle sans forcément
s'y installer il faut accepter l'idée de
la mobilité les jeunes générations sont
sans dans ces dans ces logiques là il
faut ouvrir les chakras je pense aussi
des territoires c'est-à-dire oui il faut
attirer le faciliter le retour des
jeunes
ultramarins et donc vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président la Dom est en
train de réfléchir à une nouvelle
stratégie qui va dans ce sens dans le
sens des propositions de Madame Concorde
nous avons nous le dispositif cadre
d'avenir qui est en train de se déployer
en Guadeloupe et à Saint-Martin puis qui
viendra en Guy en Martinique dont je
pourrais faire un je préfère un point
sur ce dispositif qui est propre au
ministère des Outre-mer
mais je pense que vraiment il faut aussi
accepter que des jeunes métropolitains
aillent faire un bout de carrière
dans les outre-mer et que tous ces
dispositifs d'accompagnement et
d'attractivité ne soient pas uniquement
réservé aux ultramarins parce que la
République c'est aussi le métissage je
termine en disant que les collectivités
territoriales dans cette mise en place
d'une politique attractive pour les
jeunes talons ont aussi de mon point de
vue de notre point de vue une
responsabilité il leur revient de penser
à un écosystème qui soit séduisant pour
les jeunes générations ça veut dire
avoir une une
réflexion sur le logement c'est quoi un
logement
accessible pour un jeune qui commence sa
carrière qui n'a pas forcément des gros
salaires mais qui a pris l'habitude de
vivre seul quand il est j'ai pu faire
ses études en métropole et à qui on peut
pas dire
tu as vécu dans une espèce de bulle de
liberté maintenant tu vas te réinstaller
quel que soit ton choix chez tes parents
il faut qu'il puisse avoir le choix ça
peut être un choix de rentrer chez ses
parents aussi il faut une offre
culturelle n'offre culturelle parce que
il faut pouvoir aller au cinéma pouvoir
faire du sport pour pouvoir
se cultiver il faut sans doute plus de
pépinière pour les jeunes talents des
structures ça existe dans certains
territoires des structures type village
bycéa qui sont des des lieux des
clusters où on vous accompagne dans vos
premiers pas voilà ce que je voulais
dire un peu rapidement pardon
merci beaucoup on va maintenant se
déplacer vers la Réunion et je vais
donner la parole à Monsieur fauchard
mais c'est le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs tout d'abord merci
de cette de cet échange qui nous paraît
extrêmement importante dans une période
justement où nous entreprises ont de
plus en plus de mal à recruter et ça
quel que soit le secteur d'activité quel
que soit la taille de l'entreprise et
quel que soit quelque soit sa
localisation géographique
le souligner dans sa fin de
l'intervention on ne peut pas séparer
aujourd'hui l'attractivité de l'emploi
ou la création d'emploi d'abord du
logement et je rebondis sur les propos
en les confirmant il ne peut pas y
croire de développement économique ni de
croissance si nos collaborateurs ne
disposent pas d'un logement décent et
qui est adapté en fait à l'heure
situation de famille mais au-delà du
logement il y a la deuxième
problématique qui est absolument
nécessaire de sur laquelle il faut
intervenir qui est la mobilité la
mobilité à la fois
urbaine je peux parler de la Réunion
j'habite le sud le Medef est dans le
Nord
70 km séparent Saint-Pierre et
Saint-Denis le matin c'est environ 2h30
pour circuler en voiture et il n'y a pas
d'offre de transport en commun qui
permettent aujourd'hui donc un
collaborateur habitant Saint-Pierre de
se rendre facilement à Saint-Denis ce
qui va bien entendu limiter sa recherche
d'emploi dans une zone démographique
extrêmement proche de chez lui dans la
mobilité il y a aussi le deuxième
facteur qui est la mobilité externe à la
fois la mobilité vers l'Europe et vers
l'Hexagone mais aussi la mobilité dans
une volonté dans une ambition posée par
nos régions d'outre-mer désormais de
pouvoir exporter nos produits et nos
services dans notre Grand Régional ces
deux préalable étant posés la difficulté
sur lequel nous on va désormais buter et
je voudrais quand même rappeler un
élément important parce que trop souvent
les octroies de mer peuvent être
pointées du doigt je pense en
particulier sur les litrices on l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure les chiffres pas
obligatoire sur le territoire hexagonal
c'est 1880
l'école obligatoire dans nos
départements je peux parler parfaitement
de la réunion que je connais bien
1970 ce sont donc 90 ans qui ont séparé
l'arrivée de l'école obligatoire entre
le territoire hexagonal donc nos régions
d'outre-mer en 50 ans on fait un pas
justesse qu'en avant à la fois pour
éduquer les en primaire en collège
dans les lycées et dans l'enseignement
supérieur
donc l'illettrisme aujourd'hui oui il
existe oui globalement il a diminué mais
beaucoup de choses restent à faire et en
particulier lutter contre le décrochage
scolaire les conditions de vie
aujourd'hui de nombre de nos enfants
quel que soit leur niveau scolaire font
qu'à un moment donné il est le seul de
la famille à se lever le matin pour
avoir une activité sain c'est une
situation extrêmement délétère et donc
le jeune collégien le jeune lycéen va
décrocher aux environs de 14-15 ans et
on va le voir réapparaître
socialement au travers des missions
locales à partir de 18 ans en trois ans
il aura perdu tous les repères de
socialisation il aura perdu tous les
acquis qu'il aura pu avoir d'un col
primaire au collège ou au lycée c'est
une situation qui socialement n'est pas
acceptable elle porte en elle les germes
d'une future évolution sociale à l'autre
bout du spectre nous avons effectivement
beaucoup de jeunes qui se sont formés à
la fois en local qui se sont qui sont
partis se former à l'extérieur non
seulement sur les territoires hexagonal
mais pour la Réunion en particulier au
Canada et dans les pays de l'Est et il
ne dispose pas des moyens pour revenir
pourquoi en fait autant des dispositifs
pour les inciter à partir les bourses
des tuiles existent en revanche il n'y a
pas de bourse retour
l'individu le jeune diplômé le jeune
collaborateur va devoir se débrouiller
tout seul pour revenir trouver un
logement trouver un véhicule et
s'insérer et trouver et pouvoir trouver
un emploi
l'attractivité de nos emplois allait
beaucoup plus faible quand sur le
territoire exagonal pourquoi dès que
nous sortons de notre de nos régions la
seule chose que nous avons ce sont des
pays souverains si je regarde là encore
la carte de l'océan Indien autour de la
Réunion Madagascar Maurice les Comores
l'Afrique du Sud Kenya zambique sont
aujourd'hui des pays souverains donc il
est extrêmement compliqué pour nous
d'avoir des postes intéressants puisque
les perspectives d'un développement
externe la développement exogène à nos
territoires n'est pas possible il n'est
pas possible pourquoi parce que nous
n'avons pas la capacité à nouer des
accords avec ces directs
les accords sont négociés aujourd'hui
par l'Union européenne ou par la France
à aucun moment nos territoires ne sont
invités dans ces conférences ne
serait-ce qu'à titre d'observateur
donc mettre en oeuvre une politique une
ambition internationale qui permettrait
de développer la croissance locale la
croissance tout en permettant une
croissance exogène à cet instant n'est
pas possible puisque nous ne subissons
exclusivement les accords qui ont été
noués et auxquels nous n'avons pas
participé
de A à Z voilà un petit peu en propos
liminaire en fait ce que je voulais dire
la volonté des entreprises aujourd'hui
et de l'avant de créer de l'emploi
d'aller vers plus d'inclusions d'aller
vers plus de qualité de travail d'avoir
une responsabilité sociétale et un
environnementale accrue nous avons tous
conscience que la transition écologique
et énergétique sera spécifique à le
département d'outre-mer il n'y a à cet
instant aucun élément qui nous laisse
croire qui va y avoir une adaptation de
ces politiques de transition
environnementale énergétique dans des
départements d'outre-mer
voilà monsieur le Président ce que je
souhaitais exprimer en propos
préliminaire au titre de la FEDOM
merci Monsieur mettant la parole à
Monsieur l'ortie pour la suite de cette
table ronde
merci beaucoup pour avoir organisé cette
réunion cette table ronde je suis très
heureux d'être parmi vous donc je suis
professeur d'économie à l'université
Gustave Eiffel et je dirige une
fédération de recherche du CNRS qui
s'appelle théorie évaluation des
politiques publiques qui réunit 12
laboratoires et 300 enseignants
chercheurs et nous organisons avec
beaucoup de collègues
ultramarins tous les deux ans maintenant
les journées économiques de l'outre-mer
avec de nombreux partenaires notamment
la direction générale d'outre-mer et
également le CESU qui accueille cette
cette manifestation qui a lieu tous les
années pairs donc moi je suis un
chercheur spécialiste du marché du
travail j'ai fait plusieurs travaux sur
les marchés du travail ultramarin
notamment un article était publié en
2014 qui en fait
reprend tous les thèmes qui ont été
abordés les thèmes de bien sûr de
l'ultra périphérie des problèmes de
mobilité des problèmes d'AD entre
l'offre et la demande de travail en
qualité sur les marchés du travail
ultramarin les problèmes d'accès à la
formation donc tous ces problèmes sont
connus et bien sûr contribuent à
l'explication de la surexposition du
chômage des territoires
ultramarins et mon propos va être
extrêmement ciblé en fait et partiel je
vais relater en fait brièvement deux
études qui explorent une hypothèse
complémentaire
aux difficultés
ultramarines qui est l'hypothèse donc
des discriminations à l'embauche sur le
marché du travail
l'idée c'est de c'est de
poser cette hypothèse qui peut être je
pense qu'ils jouent un rôle dans
l'explication du du chômage
ça persistance dans l'Hexagone et qui
peut également être être au moins posé
explorer pour les territoires
ultramarins donc on a réalisé deux
études
donc pour explorer les effets de cette
hypothèse la première alors ces deux
études extrêmement partiels et ciblées
aussi mais qui vous allez le voir donne
des résultats assez convergents qui
effectivement indique plutôt que oui il
y a aussi un problème de discrimination
dans l'accès à l'emploi qui amplifie
l'ensemble des autres difficultés subies
par les
ultramarins et ce problème existe à la
fois dans les territoires du tramarins
et dans l'Hexagone donc le premier test
qu'on a réalisé porte sur le secteur de
la restauration
donc pour mesurer des discriminations
assez extrêmement difficile on a un
problème d'objectivation et les méthodes
qui sont utilisées par la littérature
internationale dans ce domaine c'est des
méthodes de testing scientifique où on
fabrique en fait des fausses
candidatures qui sont semblables en tout
point sauf sur la base d'une
caractéristique dont on veut tester les
faits et on envoie ses faux candidats en
réponse à des vraies offres d'emploi
donc ça ça se fait uniquement par
correspondance on envoie des des faux CV
des fausses lettres de motivation les
protocoles sont conçus pour ne pas
perturber le marché du travail et
surtout pour ne pas surcharger les
employeurs mais et pas non plus pour
stigmatiser tel ou tel mais simplement
pour construire une une connaissance à
une observation qui est qui soit portée
relativement général sur tel ou tel
marché du travail donc en 2021 au
premier trimestre on a on a exploré la
problématique du secteur de la
restauration et de l'embauche de
serveurs donc on a
fabriqué des profils de de candidats
pour des postes de serveurs et à chaque
fois on a trois profils on a un candidat
local on a un candidat local qui habite
dans un quartier prioritaire de la
politique de la ville et on a un
candidat hexagonal et est-ce que ce que
l'on fait c'est que on a testé quatre
sites donc la ville de Paris les ou le
candidat
exogène était un Guadeloupéen on a testé
Pointe-à-Pitre Fort de France et
Saint-Denis de la Réunion et sur ces
quatre sites on a sélectionné environ
entre 250 et 300 restaurants et on a
envoyé nos trois candidats fictifs qui
ont en fait fait des demandes
d'information sur l'existence ou non de
poste à pourvoir dans le dans le
restaurant afin de pouvoir y déposer
leurs candidatures est-ce que ce qu'on a
mis en évidence donc en exploitant les
réponses à ce type de test par
correspondance à l'aide de simples
demandes d'information c'est qu'il y a
effectivement des différences
significatives statistiquement
significative dans la réception des
candidatures par les employeurs avec une
une pénalité
aux candidats locaux en outre-mer et
donc une prime au candidats hexagonale
et une situation inversée sur la ville
de Paris ou le candidat le candidat par
parisien ayant fait ses études Paris est
avantagé relativement aux candidats
guadeloupéens qui vient chercher un
emploi à Paris ça c'est donc la première
étude qui a été qui est publiée qui est
sur notre site le site de TEPP c'est
l'étude une étude je crois que c'est
2022 04 le
la référence de l'étude et puis on a
fait donc une deuxième une deuxième
étude la uniquement sur la ville de
Paris dans un autre secteur c'est le
secteur de la vente donc pour des postes
de vendeurs dans le domaine du
prêt-à-porter et de la mode on a testé
de l'ordre de 300 magasins parisiens
dans lesquels on a envoyé à chaque fois
trois candidates pour obtenir un emploi
donc il y avait une candidate
parisienne qui qui est donc dont le dont
le patronyme l'adresse beaucoup
d'éléments enfin ça trajectoire de
formation
la situation en Île-de-France
une autre candidate qui
par son patronyme et son sa localisation
son lieu de naissance qui indique qui
indiquait sur son CV et d'origine
guadeloupeéenne et on a une une
troisième et indique notamment qu'elle
parle le créole et on a une troisième
candidate qui elle est africaine
originaire d'Afrique de l'Ouest et le
protocole est conçu pour voix vérifier
s'il y a des différences selon l'origine
géographique en comparant les pénalités
subies par une candidate ultramarine
avec les pénalités subies par une
candidate d'origine africaine et
également
de façon
le protocole mesure les pénalités liées
à la couleur de la peau puisque on a
deux candidates qui sont qui sont noirs
et une candidate qui qui est blanche sur
le sur le marché du travail donc dans le
secteur de la mode à Paris et ce que met
en évidence l'étude c'est que il y a une
pénalité assez forte subite subie par
les deux candidates qui ne sont pas
qui ne sont pas blanches et le l'étude
mais en évidence le fait que c'est la
pénalité et est supérieure pour
l'africaine mais qu'elle est à peu près
enfin elle est très importante aussi
pour la candidate
ultramarine et que c'est pénalités donc
des discriminations à l'embauche elle on
les on les trouve dans le secteur de la
mode uniquement pour les magasins disons
situés sur le créneau supérieur de des
marques des magasins plutôt de luxe
alors que le prêt-à-porter on trouve pas
de différence de traitement dans le dans
les magasins de prêt-à-porter donc ça
aussi c'est une étude très intéressante
qui indique qu'effectivement il y a
aussi des discriminations à l'embauche
liées à la couleur de la peau et que les
candidats donc ultramarins sont peuvent
être victimes de ces candidats de ces de
ces discriminations voilà c'est des
études très partiels et convergentes qui
qui nous indique qui laisse à penser
qu'effectivement et il existe aussi des
discriminations sur le marché du travail
qui amplifient les problèmes subis par
les différents territoires et par les
jeunes dans ces territoires donc
des actions sans doute de
sensibilisation auprès des employeurs
pourraient être pourraient être
envisagée de façon à former les
recruteurs comme on le fait de plus en
plus dans en métropole pour tenter de
lutter contre le discrimination sachant
qu'il y a évidemment en métropole des
des études qui sont absolument
convergentes sur cette thématique
également voilà je vous remercie
merci je propose de terminer ce tour de
table préliminaire avec Madame singes
qui est en visioconférence
donc à notre niveau association Guyane
en vol l'idée était peut-être davantage
vous rapporter des retours d'expérience
assez frais notamment de jeunes diplômés
guyanais puisque l'association
intervient
auprès des jeunes 15-25 de Guyane qui
envisagent les études supérieures et
aussi on a l'occasion effectivement
d'échanger avec pas mal de jeunes
diplômés qui font partie aussi de notre
poule de mentor donc au niveau de
l'association on a essayé de regarder
effectivement sur la question
des du retour des jeunes diplômés un
petit peu les données qui existent alors
ce qu'on constate c'est que il y a pu
avoir quelques études Insee mais pour la
plupart elle commence à être un petit
peu ancienne entre 2017 et 2015 donc ça
vient déjà peut-être pointer un besoin
de réactualisation pour des territoires
qui bougent assez vite notamment pour la
Guyane au regard de son contexte donc ce
qu'on constate chez nous c'est que on a
des jeunes guyanais qui sont plus
mobiles qu'ailleurs et évidemment aussi
au regard des des données
socio-économiques qu'on connaît moins
diplômés donc ce qu'on a ce qu'on
constate c'est que en 2016 37 % des
jeunes natifs de Guyane quittent la
région pour poursuivre des études ou
trouver un emploi
et dans le même temps on a aussi environ
un tiers des jeunes des néo de
bacheliers en tout cas qui envisagent
une mobilité donc c'est non négligeable
en termes de proportion notamment par
rapport à ce qu'on observe dans
l'Hexagone
le second point aussi c'est que à côté
de ça on observe effectivement des
marchés du travail en tension et plus
particulièrement en Guyane ça c'est
objectiver aussi également ce besoin de
cadre administratif tant dans le secteur
public que dans le secteur privé en plus
aussi d'un besoin de professeur formé
face à la croissance des effectifs
scolaires donc ça c'est le cas plus
particulier de la Guyane et souvent
effectivement ce qu'on constate c'est
qu'il y a un souci de qualification qui
fait que de nombreux offres même sur des
métiers qui demandent parfois des
niveaux de diplôme moins dans mes déjà
une première base de qualification reste
finalement
peut enfin ne trouve pas de
bien en local donc une fine et ce que
l'Insee montre ses capriori 30% des
cadres
en Guyane sont des non natifs sans des
natifs moins de 30% pardon des 400 des
natifs de la région voilà donc
généralement effectivement ces emplois
s'occupaient par des personnes qui
proviennent principalement de l'Hexagone
donc du coup nous on sait on a tenté
effectivement un peu de
donner un petit peu plus de chair à ces
chiffres en interrogeant aussi notre
notre réseau de mentors ou de jeunes
étudiants et effectivement les retours
d'expérience en fait viennent plutôt
confirmer les propos qui ont été évoqués
jusqu'à présent avec effectivement des
ressources familiales qui sont cités
principalement comme le principal appui
pour pour envisager une réinstallation
après des études donc effectivement ça a
été évoqué par Madame Broca me
semble-t-il le fait de devoir revenir
chez les parents alors c'est vécu comme
une contrainte mais aussi comme une aide
puisque souvent le retour ne se ferait
pas sans cet appui familiale
puisqu'effectivement la difficulté à
trouver un logement dans on va dire des
des prix accessibles peut déjà être un
premier frein donc effectivement la
question du logement la question du coût
du déménagement sont de réels enjeux
quand on sait effectivement qu'à côté de
ça des fonctionnaires provenant de
l'Hexagone peuvent être accompagnés de
manière très soutenante sur ces sujets
là et quand effectivement on envisage un
retour au pays dans le secteur privé ou
parfois sans même avoir de visibilité
sur un emploi dans les trois six mois la
question du de l'aide financière se pose
ce qu'on a vu
c'est que en Guyane en tout cas des
initiatives commencent à être réfléchies
au niveau des collectivités
territoriales donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
un an la CTG avait annoncé la mise en
place d'un dispositif d'aide au retour
n'est pas encore effectif mais en tout
cas ça ça
a suscité beaucoup d'attention
puisqu'effectivement la mobilité le prix
du billet le coût du fret qui sont des
enjeux qui ont été bien repérés et qui
sont en tout cas qui sont soulignés
comme de réels contraintes ensuite c'est
la question de l'accès à l'emploi dans
nos dans notre réseau effectivement un
certain nombre de personnes
sans rentrer sans avoir forcément de
visibilité sur les offres d'emploi en
local et en activer la démarche de
retour parfois avant même d'avoir une
promesse d'embauche donc c'est vraiment
une question de on va dire de
détermination et de volonté de rentrer
après un premier temps de carrière ou
juste après les études et
la plupart du temps effectivement ce qui
est souligné et ça a déjà été dit c'est
vraiment le manque de visibilité sur les
opportunités en local et souvent ce qui
va faire que ça fonctionne c'est du
bouche à oreille le bouche à oreille est
vu comme vraiment le réseau en fait
personnel est vu vraiment comme un
facteur accélérant facilitant mais du
coup qui est susceptible aussi
d'interroger l'équité dans les dans les
l'accès aux offres d'emploi donc du coup
ce qui a été effectivement proposé et je
pourrais rapidement vous faire remonter
voilà quelques quelques pistes de
solutions
perçues par les jeunes diplômés en tout
cas en Guyane
la question aussi qui se pose c'est
comment mieux mobiliser les dispositifs
existants donc on a évoqué la Dom avec
une réforme qui est en cours et c'est
vrai que finalement ce sont des
dispositifs qui ne sont pas du tout
utilisées quand il s'agit de penser un
retour au pays on connaît plutôt ces
dispositifs quand il s'agit de partir
faire des études avec une communication
on va dire qui au niveau de la Dom qui
touche déjà maintenant plutôt bien les
les jeunes lycéens toutefois
effectivement pour le retour peu de
dispositifs existent tant au niveau de
des agences qu'au niveau des
collectivités territoriales donc des
choses sont à construire en partant en
parlant toutefois de dispositif on ne
part pas non plus totalement d'intérêt
vierge puisque
plusieurs initiatives ont existé
notamment à l'échelle de la Région
Guyane pour faciliter l'attractivité des
jeunes diplômés on regrette toutefois
qu'elle n'est pas pu être pérennisé dans
le temps donc je pense notamment au
montage d'une association
Eric défi à l'impulsion de la régie la
Région Guyane pardon qui se voulait une
pépinière de jeunes diplômés de Guyane
qui a fonctionné principalement entre
1995 et 2008 avant d'être fusionné avec
l'organisme régional de la formation
professionnelle l'opprf donc sur cette
période
d'une petite quinzaine d'années on a
recensé à peu près 120 jeunes diplômés
accompagné insérer sur le marché de
l'emploi
à partir donc jeunes diplômé à partir
d'un bac + 2 et âgé de moins de 30 ans
donc souvent effectivement leur proposer
des
des premières expériences de stage
d'alternance ou de tout premier emploi
en local avec en perspective
effectivement le fait de pouvoir
décrocher un CDI au sein de la de la
structure accueillante
donc le dispositif malheureusement n'a
pas eu le temps de prospérer dans le
temps
il y a également eu passerelle vers
l'emploi toujours à l'initiative du
Conseil régional qu'ils a lutter contre
le chômage des jeunes diplômés donc avec
une volonté effectivement de décliner
une offre de recensement des jeunes
diplômés et de référencement des
entreprises locales d'accompagner ces
derniers vers l'emploi et d'assister
aussi les entreprises pour faciliter
l'embauche toutefois on dispose de peu
de visibilité sur finalement les
résultats de cette initiative qui de
tout est passons a pris fin avec la
fermeture de l'OPF l'an dernier donc
finalement ce qu'on constate c'est que
le terrain n'est pas totalement vierge
soit des initiatives qui ont existé qui
n'ont pas pu être pérennisées en local
soit effectivement
des secteurs des enfin des extensions de
dispositifs je pense notamment à la Dom
à réaliser donc c'est une bonne chose
que qu'une réforme soit en cours et
effectivement en termes de proposition
ce qui remonte c'est effectivement la de
la base de données des étudiants c'est à
dire ce sont les futurs jeunes diplômés
il est nécessaire de pouvoir les suivre
pour communiquer auprès de sur les
offres d'emploi on a évoqué une GPEC un
petit peu plus tôt c'est nécessaire
effectivement que les entreprises
administration en tout cas les gros
secteurs de recrutement puissent
communiquer deux trois ans à l'avance
sur les perspectives de recrutement
l'idée étant de préparer aussi les
jeunes à un retour sur les perspectives
en connaissance de cause en fait la
question donc du coup d'une bourse à
l'emploi d'une bourse aussi au logement
a été posée donc notamment la
proposition de logements transitoire en
Guyane le marché de du logement
extrêmement tendu on a des prix de loyer
similaires à ce qu'on retrouve dans la
banlieue parisienne avec pourtant
parfois des
des comment dire
des salaires qui ne correspondent pas
tout à fait notamment qu'on ne peut pas
bénéficier des 40% de vie chers comme un
certain nombre de fonctionnaires donc du
coup c'est peut-être des partenariats à
travailler davantage avec le monde des
entreprises avec Action Logement
pourquoi pas pour favoriser aussi
effectivement
l'accession à des logements pour des
jeunes diplômés donc en mobilité depuis
l'hexagone dans un contexte qui est déjà
globalement très tendu il y a également
effectivement la question
des offres de stage qui a été évoquées
plutôt et c'est un enjeu réel puisque
souvent si on n'a pas fait plusieurs
stages en Guyane si on n'a pas eu
l'occasion de pouvoir en réaliser il est
compliqué de se créer un réseau en local
donc c'est vrai que l'initiative de
l'association c'est de pouvoir pallier
ce manque de réseau en mettant à
disposition des jeunes en études des
mentors déjà en poste et plus
susceptible de favoriser l'accès à des
offres de stage mais effectivement c'est
un souci réel il n'y a pas de visibilité
sur ces dernières les jeunes principes
ne savent pas comment se positionner
qu'il soit d'ailleurs déjà en Guyane ou
qu'il soit à l'Hexagone c'est un réel
souci
donc du coup effectivement ce sont des
questions qui demandent que chaque
niveau d'échelle se positionne
collectivité puissance publique était à
collectivité territoriale entreprise et
puis aussi la société civile et c'est
vrai que nous à notre niveau
effectivement associatif lui un envol
l'idée était de pouvoir en tout cas
aussi
proposer à force de proposition sur la
question du suivi des étudiants donc
nous sommes aussi nous avons sollicité
la collectivité territoriale pour
pouvoir travailler sur un projet de base
étudiante donc de base de données
étudiantes donc nous espérons à terme
que ce projet pourra trouver un écho
favorable sachant que des données
existent qu'elles sont disparaître et
que pour le moment elles ne sont pas
exploitées de manière à faciliter
l'appariement en fait entre entre les
futurs besoins d'emploi et les besoins
existants voilà je ne serai pas plus
longue
et je me tiens bien entendu à
disposition pour tout complément
d'information
merci beaucoup je vais maintenant donner
la distribuer la parole à ceux qui le
souhaiteront dans la salle Marie-Laure
finira Horse signatrice de Guyane
enlever la main
merci président bonjour à tous alors ma
question s'adresse à Cynthia
René Sagne
alors bien souvent quand je prends la
parole je souligne souvent les
spécificités de la Guyane sur bien des
situations car je pense qu'il est utile
d'apporter un éclairage à mes collègues
sur mon territoire il est très difficile
d'entreprendre en Guyane même avec un
bon diplôme et l'expérience entre les
banques et les démarches administratives
c'est souvent le renoncement plutôt que
l'aboutissement d'ailleurs
dernièrement j'ai organisé une
conférence des balles le 18 avril
dernier en Guyane avec pour thème être
jeune et acteur du développement de la
Guyane afin d'écouter les doléances mais
aussi les espoirs de notre jeunesse
c'est vrai que suite à cette conférence
débats suivront des causeries parce que
je crois que la jeunesse guyanaise est
très demande
alors Cynthia
excusez-moi je l'appelle Cynthia parce
que je la connais très bien alors de par
ton expérience personnelle et
associative aurais-tu des pistes à
préconiser afin d'encourager les jeunes
porteurs de projets parce qu'il y en a
mais les malheureux ils sont bloqués
parce qu'ils savent pas où aller tu
parlais de réseau tout à l'heure et je
crois que c'est important de communiquer
parce qu'il frappe à des portes et en
fait ils n'obtiennent pas de réponse et
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut il repartent
en France hexagonale tout simplement
alors qu'on a besoin de ces matières
grises chez nous on a besoin de
développer le pays et c'est triste donc
je qu'est-ce que tu aurais comme piste à
proposer à ces jeunes porteurs de
projets merci
bonjour à Madame finirard c'est un
plaisir de vous retrouver ici alors
effectivement bon en termes de
proposition ça a déjà été ça a été déjà
été évoquée alors pour les porteurs de
projets en tant que tel on n'a pas fait
on n'a pas fait de focus effectivement
bon généralement ce qu'on constate c'est
que les obstacles et les contraintes
sont parfois plus élevées en Guyane même
si effectivement il y a tout à fait
donc pour beaucoup de de jeunes ce qui
va d'abord revenir en premier lieu c'est
le manque d'information en dépit du
caractère plutôt enfin ce sont des
petits marchés
voilà une population certes en forte
croissance mais le réseau peut
facilement être créé en profitant en
faisant de cette petite tête si je puis
dire un atout c'est à dire celui de la
proximité et ce qu'on constate c'est
qu'effectivement cette proximité qui
pourrait être facilement stimulé ne
l'est pas et donc du coup conduit à un
manque d'informations et de visibilité
donc la question effectivement de rendre
accessible les opportunités ça c'est un
réel enjeu
les jeunes ne diplômés effectivement
sont souvent à la recherche un petit peu
de des entreprises qui seront
susceptibles de recruter dans certains
domaines c'est elle qui ont beaucoup de
visibilité
je pense par exemple dans le domaine de
l'aérospatiale qui effectivement joue
son rôle en
accueillant un certain nombre de jeunes
diplômés
voilà pour un étudiant à l'heure
actuelle qui qui se lance dans des
études en lien avec ce secteur il n'a
pas forcément de visibilité à l'issue de
ses études sur les opportunités d'emploi
donc je pense qu'effectivement donner
enfin en tout cas coordonner
les projections des entreprises du
secteur public privé pour donner à voir
effectivement
pouvoir permettre aux jeunes de se
projeter et tu un premier pas l'accès à
l'information tout simplement
le deuxième point c'est effectivement
aussi contre pour enfin lutter contre le
découragement et se dire que ça va être
trop compliqué c'est donner à voir
l'exemplarité je pense qu'on pourrait
encore davantage communiquer sur les
porteurs de projets les jeunes diplômés
aussi salariés qui se lancent et
parviennent effectivement à faire
aboutir en tout cas faire déjà décoller
leurs projets je pense que c'est
important qu'on est davantage aussi de
visibilité sur ces derniers
puisque ça inspire et c'est vrai que on
constate nous qu'on passe dans les
lycées
que pour un jeune
qui vient d'un quartier difficile de la
ville de Saint-Laurent-du-Maroni qui
souvent en fait ne parle pas forcément
par le Français dans la famille donc
c'est un atout en soi il est bilingue
thrillingue mais ça peut devenir une
difficulté dans le système scolaire
actuel quand une voix qu'une personne
est passée par un petit peu le même
parcours que lui-même a grandi parfois
dans des quartiers un peu compliqués
voir que cette personne plusieurs années
plus tard est une jeune cadre à pur
réussi c'est un modèle inspirant et on
sent que ça peut stimuler en fait c'est
le manque de perspective et le manque
d'exemple aussi derrière qui peut aussi
tout simplement
alors avant même de s'autocensurer on
s'autocensure parce que on a déjà
l'information que ça existe on se dit
que c'est pas fait pour soi déjà on n'a
pas d'information on s'imagine même pas
parfois pour certains jeunes que c'est
possible d'y arriver donc il y a
vraiment un enjeu de stimuler d'ouvrir
le champ des possibles et effectivement
dans un deuxième temps et de façon
concomitante il lutter contre
l'autocensure voilà donc c'est un peu
vaste il y a énormément de choses à
explorer mais c'est déjà enfin peut-être
les deux pistes qui qui nous a semblés
qui nous ont semblé prioritaire à notre
niveau
merci je vais m'étendre donner la parole
à Michel Canevet et ensuite madame Broca
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues Mesdames et Messieurs le
président babary et la délégation en
sénatoriale aux entreprises ont souhaité
que nous puissions mener un travail sur
les questions de formation compétences
attractivité des métiers nous rendons
compte qu'en contact de nombreux
entrepreneurs dans l'Hexagone
ceux-ci sont affrontés à difficulté de
recrutement et de réponse à leurs
besoins en main d'oeuvre alors même que
nous avons des statistiques qui sont
considérables concernant le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi dans dans notre pays
mais c'est vrai que nous n'avons pas
l'occasion d'aller en outre-mer et cette
table ronde et bienvenue parce que
effectivement elle permet de porter
l'accent particulier sur les
problématiques spécifiques qu'elles sont
nombreuses on vient de l'entendre à
l'instant de l'outre-mer ceci montre
bien Madame la Directrice Générale qui
reste encore
beaucoup de chemins à parcourir pour que
nous pêchons arriver à un niveau de
satisfaction et de développement des
Outre-mer des territoires et
départements d'outre-mer qui soient
satisfaisant cela montre bien aussi
qu'il y a un besoin d'accompagnement
extrêmement significatif sur un certain
nombre d'initiatives sachant que les
thématiques sont sans doute et des
besoins sont sans doute un peu
différents suivant les territoires dont
on parle il faut aussi pouvoir s'adapter
aux spécificités de chacun des
territoires de d'outre-mer même s'il
peut y avoir des fils conducteurs bien
entendu pour l'ensemble des territoires
alors mes questions seront seront le
suivant d'abord sur la question de la
difficulté à fidéliser et attirer les
jeunes qu'on a beaucoup évoqué au sein
des entreprises
ultamarines est-ce que c'est un problème
d'activité ou est-ce que c'est un
problème d'offre de formation sur place
selon vous quels sont les leviers sur
lesquels on peut s'appuyer pour pour
cela ensuite concernant l'attractivité
des entreprises et des emplois à notre
mère quelles sont selon vous les
principaux points de blocage est-ce que
c'est une question de rémunération par
exemple lié au cours de la vie en
outre-mer ou est-ce que c'est un danger
d'accès au service aux infrastructures
aux loisirs aussi a été évoqué aussi
notamment pour pour la réunion pour les
loisirs vous l'avez évoqué madame récré
général et notamment bien entendu pour
les jeunes et puis
à l'oral
alors que nous sommes en train de
préparer je dirais une réforme des
dispositifs
d'accompagnement au travail dans notre
pays quelle est l'accompagnement des
jeunes demandeurs d'emploi on a
l'expérience ici de la Guyane et de
l'association Guyane l'envol qui est
intéressant mais comment se passe les
choses avec le service public de
l'emploi sur chacun des territoires
ultramarins en quelque sorte
vous voulez d'abord intervenir avant de
d'apporter des éléments de réponse en ce
qui vous concerne peut-être je voulais
monsieur le Président peut-être apporter
quelques éléments par rapport à la
question de poser par madame la
sénatrice sur l'accompagnement des
créateurs d'entreprise peut-être on va
répondre à devoir avec Isabelle pour
pour les créateurs d'entreprise Vous
avez raison madame la sénatrice il y a
des il y a des jeunes talents qui ont
envie de créer leur job créent leur
entreprise on a vu enfin j'ai essayé de
lister toutes les difficultés qui
s'attachent de notre point de vue à la
création d'entreprise ou à la au
développement des entreprises d'une
façon générale dans les outre-mer mais
je voudrais signaler quand même qu'il y
a certaines expériences qu'il faut avoir
en tête face à certains organismes ou
certains dispositifs qui peuvent aider
les créateurs d'entreprise à faire ce
premier pas à s'installer etc c'est
d'abord Lady qui est très présente dans
les outre-mer que nous soutenons
financièrement au même titre que nous
soutenons au ministère des Outre-mer
France Active et initiative France
Initiative outre-mer mais c'est 11800
bénéficiaires l'année dernière et 70
millions d'aides de micro de près sur
l'honneur de garantie de près qui ont
été accordés c'est vraiment leur métier
d'accompagner les premiers pas du
créateur d'entreprise il a dit ça permet
aussi de sortir de l'informel de
s'installer d'être de se mettre à son
compte
d'ailleurs on encourage d'abord on
encourageait ces trois structures l'a
dit France Active et initiative
outre-mer à faire un pacte une coalition
pour pouvoir accompagner un chef
d'entreprise un créateur d'entreprise
des premiers jours de sa naissance
jusqu'à sa maturité puisque ces trois
organismes n'ont pas ni les mêmes
instruments pour intervenir ni les mêmes
cibles d'entreprises donc voilà j'espère
que cette coalition va bientôt être
rendu public et permettre aux créateurs
d'entreprises de savoir vers qui se
tourner ensuite je voulais signaler que
lundi et le SMA service militaire adapté
qui est une structure propre aux
outre-mer et qui est d'ailleurs a des
succès je crois parce que ils ont une
offre de formation qui est très encadrée
dans un dans un cadre militaire ça
convient à certains jeunes et pas à
d'autres mais très bons résultats en
termes de d'insertion professionnelle
parce que ils sont proches des
entreprises les régiments du SMA voit
les entreprises connaissent des
entreprises et savent qu'elles sont
leurs besoins en formation et ils
mettent en regard les formations en
place par rapport aux besoins du
territoire le résultat c'est qu'ils ont
80% de sortie
82% de sortie positive dont 53% dans
l'emploi durable et tous les jeunes
sortent avec leur permis de conduire
pour essayer de contrebattre les
problèmes de mobilité et l'absence de
transport en commun qui a été qui ont
été évoqués donc Lady et le SMA sont en
train de s'entendre pour que à la sortie
du SMA le jeune qui a appris à faire de
la plomberie de la menuiserie de la
soudure de la peinture et s'il le
souhaite s'il souhaite aller vers sa
propre entreprise et puisse être
accompagné je pense que je voulais
signaler ça je voulais signaler une
autre une autre initiative vous avez
raison il y a des chefs d'entreprise il
y a des talents des jeunes des startups
des startups dans les dans les outre-mer
il faut les mettre en valeur ce sont des
héros positifs ce sont des figures
positives pour leur père il faut les
mettre en valeur c'est ce que fait par
exemple outre network chaque année avec
la remise enfin toute une soirée de
remise de prix
à ces jeunes startupeurs ultramarins à
la station F évidemment c'est quelque
chose qu'on soutient pour répondre à
monsieur le sénateur
alors
je vais avec Isabelle Richard peut-être
l'attractivité du métier vous vous
demandiez monsieur le sénateur est-ce
que c'est un problème de salaire
d'écosystème je crois que c'est tout à
la fois mais c'est aussi ce qui a été
souligné par plusieurs intervenants
notamment par la jeune femme de
Guyane est long c'est ça
il y en vole pardon va envol et lance
pareil c'est voler de ses propres ailes
c'est qu'il y a pas de visibilité sur
les offres il y a ce marché gris ce
marché ce marché de l'offre d'emploi qui
n'apparaît nulle part et qui ne se passe
enfin qui ne et qui ne fonctionne que
par le bouche à oreille et le réseau
donc là je crois qu'il faut vraiment
aller vers quelque chose qui qui
permette de donner de la visibilité aux
offres de stage d'apprentissage d'emploi
pour pour les jeunes diplômés après le
problème de salaire où sans doute parce
qu'il y a un surcoût dans les outre-mer
et ça ça c'est une question beaucoup
plus systémique
[Musique]
je crois que c'est aussi ce que disait
monsieur de Monsieur le vice-président
laidum à la Réunion tout à l'heure je
pense qu'effectivement le fait qu'il y
ait pas il est pas assez de commerce
dans le bassin et en effet il faut
libérer
la possibilité pour les territoires
ultramarins de négocier de commercer
avec leurs voisins
il faut il faut aussi que partir pour un
jeune dans un territoire bon si on y est
peut-être que c'est envisageable mais
partir dans un territoire qui est une
île en se disant qu'on va y passer toute
sa vie c'est pas voilà il faut ces
jeunes générations ont besoin de
perspective de mobilité et je note que
personne ne l'a évoqué cette question de
la mobilité au sens de
on peut très bien envisager un retour
dans les outre-mer pour 5 ans avant de
repartir ailleurs
on peut en faire une étape de carrière
parce que c'est des lieux où il faut
être plus créatif plus adaptable voilà
nous c'est ce qu'on explique aux
fonctionnaires aussi voilà il faut et ça
personne on a l'impression que le retour
c'est le retour pour la vie mais les
jeunes générations elles sont elles sont
pas dans cette idée là que c'est
définitifs elles sont dans l'idée de la
mobilité des réseaux de l'aller et venir
voilà l'accompagnement des jeunes je
vais donner la parole Isabelle le
service public de l'emploi il est le
même en métropole et outre-mer donc
voilà et la Réunion est
territoire expérimentateur pour France
travail pour la mise en place de France
travail
[Musique]
Isabelle peut-être vous voulez
simplement pour ajouter que
effectivement les réseaux qu'on nous
avions pu interroger nous des GEM les
réseaux d'étudiants ou les associations
telles que Guyane en vol nous ont
souvent pointé effectivement peut-être
des salaires plus faibles ou trop mères
pour un jeune qui aurait fait ses études
en métropole qu'effectivement qu'un
emploi qu'il aurait pu trouver qu'il est
qu'il aurait pu trouver ici dans
l'Hexagone mais effectivement il n'y a
pas que ces questions de salaire déjà
premièrement il y a des outils qui
permettraient aux entreprises quand même
de faire un effort sur ses salaires
puisqu'il y a des exonérations de charge
sociale très importante outre-mer les
exonérations l'odéum et je pense
qu'elles peuvent être un levier pour
proposer quelquefois des salaires plus
attractifs je pense que les entreprises
doivent avoir envie de recruter ces
jeunes il faut vraiment qu'il y ait une
volonté de les attirer à par tout moyen
mais le salaire n'est pas la seule
réponse je pense qu'on vient de parler
un petit peu de sens pour les jeunes il
y a le la mobilité effectivement ils
veulent pas se sentir enfermé par par un
seul train un seul travail toute leur
vie une seule orientation
professionnelle toute leur vie et puis
aussi surtout le sens souvent les jeunes
nous disent qu'ils sont prêts à accepter
vers un travail peut-être moins bien
rémunéré mais pas condition qu'il soit
porteurs de sens et je pense qu'encore
encore encore une fois les entreprises
doivent absolument avoir cette réflexion
sur les attentes des jeunes et peut-être
une réflexion commun au sein des
organisations patronales au sein de au
sein de la FEDOM sur ce qu'attendent les
jeunes pour que les entreprises puissent
mieux répondre à ces attentes et je
pense aussi que les nécessaires de
s'ouvrir par évidemment ce qu'on obtient
d'indiquer les stages les stages
l'apprentissage donc il y a sans doute
aussi un problème comme l'indiqué Guyane
en vol de visibilité de tous les outils
utiles pour les jeunes il faut il faudra
vraiment qu'on y travaille aussi en
partenariat avec toutes les instances
compétentes en la matière parce qu'il y
a aussi le programme initiative jeune
qui permet aussi accompagner un projet
un projet entrepreneurial des jeunes
c'est quand même voilà une dotation qui
avait été abondée lors du plan de
relance qui existe toujours qui peut
être utile donc c'est un exemple aussi
d'outils pour pour aider un projet de
jeune ou trois mères et il faut vraiment
sans doute insister sur la mise en
cohérence de toute de toutes ces aides
sans doute la réforme avec la création
de France travail va peut-être nous y
aider puisque vous avez sans doute noté
ce récent rapport et la volonté du
gouvernement voilà de proposer bientôt
un projet de loi France travail pour
essayer de mettre en cohérence davantage
tous ces acteurs c'est un besoin qui
était ressentis au niveau national et
qui pourrait être utile aussi pour au
niveau des au niveau des outre-mares
pardon je reprends la parole parce que
monsieur le sénateur vous avez aussi
posé je crois la question de l'offre de
formation sur place alors là vous avez
raison c'est un sujet il y a des
universités partout
naturellement sur des territoires qui
comptent 300.000 personnes
ou presque un million à la Réunion c'est
difficile d'avoir une offre de formation
absolument enfin sur tous les vantail je
parle des formations universitaires sur
tous les vantails je pense qu'il faut
progresser pour pour inciter les
universités à développer des formations
qui sont en lien avec les besoins du
territoire et de fait sa progresse
puisque par exemple
aux Antilles il va y avoir un cursus
pour médical
complet jusqu'à présent ne pouvait faire
qu'une partie de ses études de médecine
sur place
donc voilà l'université de Mayotte est
en train aussi de d'ouvrir des nouvelles
des nouvelles formations donc ça
progresse mais je pense qu'il faut pas
se raconter d'histoires en offrira
jamais tous les vantails et d'ailleurs
un jeune qui vit en Ardèche dans les
Landes ou je sais pas où il est obligé
aussi de quitter son territoire parce
que sur place il ne trouve pas tous les
vantails alors
on peut faire on peut faire des choses
nouvelles maintenant avec la
connectivité avec les câbles sous-marins
c'est ainsi par exemple à
Wallis-et-Futuna on a créé une
université connectée avec Nouméa et ce
qui permet à des jeunes Wallisiens de
rester sur place pour des enseignements
en gestion et en droit mais tout ne peut
pas se faire à distance non plus
sur le l'enseignement supérieur que je
veux dire un mot peut-être de
l'apprentissage sur l'enseignement
supérieur donc il y a l'idée du départ
avec qui est accompagné avec les bourses
de la Dom etc on est en train de
travailler à des à des aides au retour
comme vous l'avez tous souligné les uns
et les autres nous avons développé un
dispositif qui s'appelle cadre d'avenir
dont je dis un mot qui existe
aujourd'hui en Nouvelle-Calédonie à
Mayotte cette année en Guadeloupe et à
Saint-Martin l'année prochaine en
Martinique et poursuivre sans doute la
Guyane de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit de
repérer des jeunes des jeunes bacheliers
à potentiel ou des jeunes étudiants des
deux premières années à potentiel
d'origine modeste et de leur proposer de
rentrer dans le dispositif cadre
d'avenir qui va financer leur
déplacements jusqu'en métropole
évidemment leur formation universitaire
avec une bourse mensuelle
[Musique]
de directeur d'hôtel ils ont besoin dans
le BTP de directeur de chantier ils ont
besoin dans les entreprises
d'expert-comptables et d'ingénieurs
voilà mais tous les tous les secteurs
sont sont couverts et donc ce dispositif
cadre d'avenir c'est un moyen aussi de
fidéliser les jeunes pour les aider à
rentrer
trois demandes de prise de parole dans
l'ordre vivent Lopez monsieur chavignat
et ensuite le président barbarie
oui merci monsieur le Président bonjour
à toutes et à tous
je voudrais revenir sur ce qu'a dit tout
à l'heure monsieur l'ortie vous avez
parlé de la discrimination à cause de la
couleur de la peau mais je pense aussi
qu'il y a de la discrimination en
fonction du physique un jeune fille ou
garçon qui aura plus de chance d'être en
beauté Baucher surtout dans certains
milieux s'il a un physique je vais dire
entre guillemets de mannequin plutôt que
quelqu'un qui sera un peu enveloppé je
pense que c'est plus compliqué on n'a
pas évoqué du tout non plus les jeunes
qui sont handicapés ça aussi c'est un
gros problème
discrimination madame Broca vous lavez
parlé de la mobilité mais parce qu'un
jeune que ça soit un autre maire ou en
métropole à plus de difficultés si dans
un milieu rural ou en milieu urbain et
ça c'est un gros problème
il faut également évoquer le jeûne qui
n'aime pas du tout ou qui ne se sent pas
du tout à l'aise dans le milieu scolaire
et moi je pense qu'il faudrait qu'il
puisse être orienté rapidement vers
l'apprentissage mais la difficulté pour
les jeunes que ce soit notre mère ou à
métropole c'est pareil je pense pour
trouver des stages ou des contrats
d'apprentissage ça relève de l'exploit
s'ils n'ont pas quelqu'un pour les aider
pour les appuyer je vais dire bon ben ma
foi ça fonctionne encore les
connaissances la question du logement
qui est effectivement un sujet
primordial on se rend compte par exemple
que dans la restauration on n'arrive
plus du tout à trouver de jeunes parce
qu'ils étaient logés dans des conditions
indécentes bien souvent des des
logements insalubre des prix
inabordables surtout quand vous êtes en
pleine saison que ce soit sur le
littoral ou en montagne en pleine saison
d'hiver
et puis d'autre part je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de jeunes qui ne connaissent
pas tous les métiers qui sont à leur
portée comme vous l'avez évoqué madame
Broca la pose des câbles sous-marins par
exemple je suis sûr et certain que
beaucoup de jeux ne savent même pas
comment ça fonctionne ils sont branchés
connectés à leur téléphone pourvu que ça
marche ou Internet mais ils ne savent
pas du tout comment ça arrive donc je
pense que ça d'ailleurs nous avons
souvent évoqué tous les métiers liés à
la mer c'est ce que l'on dit bien
souvent notre mère vous êtes entouré
d'eau et pourtant les jeunes ne se
tournent pas du tout vers la mer et
pourtant c'est pertinemment
qu'aujourd'hui l'avenir va s'écrire avec
la mère donc je crois que tout ça ce
sont des gros problèmes dont on parle
mais il faudra peut-être un jour ou
l'autre on arrive à trouver vraiment les
solutions parce que elles existent mais
je ne sais pas pourquoi on n'arrive pas
à déverrouiller tout cela que les jeunes
donc puissenter leur plus jeune âge si
le milieu scol
merci de me donner la parole donc Pascal
Chavagnat je suis le directeur des
ressources humaines de GBH qui est un
acteur important de l'emploi en
outre-mer je voudrais revenir sur deux
ou trois points qui ont été évoqués
monsieur le sénateur vous parliez
d'attractivité en disant finalement
est-ce que c'est un problème de salaire
ou de qualification je rejoins plutôt ce
qui a été dit c'est quand quelqu'un
s'interroge sur l'attractivité d'un
emploi en réalité il s'interroge sur des
problématiques d'attractivité beaucoup
plus globale pour les mathématiques de
logement qui ont été évoqués
problématiques de qualité des soins
médicaux qualités des écoles qualités
des universités problématiques de
d'emploi du conjoint si ou de la
conjointe si je bouge est-ce que mon
conjoint aussi je reviens est-ce que mon
conjoint ma conjoint est effectivement
est en mesure de trouver un emploi
est-ce qu'il sera accompagné etc etc
donc la problématique de l'attractivité
de l'emploi passe avant tout par
problématique d'attractivité qui est qui
est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus globale
je rejoins beaucoup ce qui était dit par
Madame roquette tout à l'heure sur le
fait qu'il faut s'habituer aujourd'hui à
avoir des jeunes qui reviennent ou qui
viennent tout simplement et dont
l'outre-mer n'est qu'une partie de
parcours et la question en terminerache
à partir de là c'est globalement comment
est-ce que je valorise mon parcours
effectué en outre-mer alors même que les
représentations et enfin en tout cas
c'est mon sentiment elle représentations
qu'on a de nos territoires quand on est
à l'extérieur je sais pas s'il existe
des études qui montreraient comment les
territoires sont perçus à l'extérieur
au-delà d'une problématique de tourisme
que ça c'est sympa le tourisme ça génère
de l'emploi etc mais au-delà du Tourisme
quels sont les autres présentations que
l'on a des territoires lorsqu'on a à
l'extérieur je serai vraiment intéressé
d'une étude sur le sujet parce que pour
le coup je pense que que les territoires
sont vus au travers ouvrez les
guillemets de leur caricatures et or il
n'y a pas que des caricatures sur les
territoires et très loin sans faux il y
a beaucoup d'opportunités beaucoup de
points qui sont extrêmement positifs et
je pense qu'il faudrait vraiment penser
à aller à les valoriser
madame Broca vous avez évoqué deux
choses sur lesquelles faudrait revenir
en réponse à monsieur le sénateur canvé
vous avez évoqué donc le RSMA et
effectivement c'est un acteur
extrêmement important de l'emploi et en
particulier de l'emploi des jeunes qui
sont les plus éloignés de l'emploi sur
les territoires et de ce point de vue
nous menons aujourd'hui une initiative
avec le RSMA en Martinique qui vise à
créer une filière de d'insertion de
formation et d'emploi pour des jeunes
mécaniciens puisque ce sont des métiers
dont on manque beaucoup et j'ai bon
espoir que on devrait faire une
conférence de presse on est quelques
semaines qui qui viennent pour annoncer
un projet important avec le RSMA en
Martinique et également en Guyane
prochainement je l'espère et vous
évoquez monsieur le sénateur donc les
services publics de l'emploi là aussi
pour moi je crois que c'est vraiment un
levier extrêmement important que les
entreprises alors j'ai la chance le DRH
d'un groupe assez important et qui
recrute beaucoup mais on doit vraiment
travailler en très étroite collaboration
avec les services publics de l'emploi et
je voudrais citer une initiative que
nous avons pris donc GBH et Pôle emploi
en Martinique nous avons créé depuis
maintenant deux ans le premier Salon
Régional de qui s'appelle Martinique
pour l'emploi et qui permet donc pendant
un certain nombre de journées au mois de
septembre donc à tous les employeurs de
venir participer à un salon comme on le
fait un petit peu Ici Paris pour
l'emploi ou à la réunion avec le GIR par
exemple pour le coup les offres sont
vraiment toutes les offres d'emploi sont
visibles et en général on a pratiquement
250 offres d'emploi tout employeurs
confondus et c'est l'occasion donc pour
des candidats de candidater à la fois en
digital et à la fois physiquement lors
d'un salon qui est organisé à l'Hôtel
Batelière en Martinique donc les alors
il y a un certain nombre de freins ils
ont été évoqués j'y reviendrai pas mais
il y a aussi un certain nombre de
leviers un certain nombre d'opportunités
et je reviens sur ce que vous disiez
monsieur le Président Artano vous
parliez d'ingénierie tout à l'heure et
effectivement une des clés de la
réussite c'est d'être innovant si on est
sur nos territoires en matière d'emploi
à essayer de déployer des recettes
cuites et recuites c'est clair qu'on va
pas sortir quoi donc il faut être
innovant dans la post dans la capacité
que nous avons à imaginer et à monter
des dispositifs nouveaux et qui voilà
qui s'appuie sur les acteurs des
territoires
alors victoire jasmin et ensuite
monsieur fauchard
ton micro
vas-y c'est bon victoire
à tous et au collègues mais je remercie
les différents intervenants pour leurs
différentes interventions qui sont très
intéressantes alors je ne vais pas
revenir ce qui a été dit et que le Japon
seulement concernant les problématiques
l'illettrisme au territoire alors je
voudrais poser la question est-ce que
les critères de dotation des moyens pour
les différents établissements pour le
rectorat en tout cas pour l'éducation
nationale particuliers les critères de
dotation des moyens humains des moyens
personnels ne serait pas parce que très
souvent ancien compte des effectifs Obs
par exemple c'est le cas en ce moment
dans les différents niveaux
dans l'attente peut-être une reconnexion
de victoire je propose de donner la
parole à Monsieur fauchard
merci monsieur le Président juste pour
témoigner et répondre à la première
question posée par la sénatrice de
Guyane nous avons mené une
expérimentation sur la réunion au niveau
de la création de d'entreprise au niveau
du Medef au travers d'une entreprise
2022 le programme la création
d'entreprise en 2022 qui était financé
par le Fond Social Européen on a donc
accompagné 75 porteurs de projets la
particularité étant que durant la
formation au-delà de la formation
classique du adversale d'entreprise on a
énormément travaillé sur l'estime de soi
et la confiance en soi et dans la mesure
où ils étaient dans nos locaux pour la 9
semaines donc les porteurs de projets
qui avaient besoin de
fignoler j'allais dire leur projet de le
peaufiner
l'accès à nos 800 adhérents
immédiatement puisqu'on leur a ouvert en
fait notre fichier la nomination on a
nommé un mentor chef d'entreprise qui
les a accompagnés là aussi et puis un
groupe de chefs d'entreprise qui permet
qui leur permettait de poser la question
donc ça a donné 75% de projets dont
aujourd'hui 42 ont créé leur entreprise
et c'est même porteurs de projets qui
ont désormais créé leur entreprise
sont accompagnés par le MEDEF dans une
phase qu'on appelle pas qu'expert où là
cette fois-ci en fait il partage
bénéficier d'accompagnement gratuit de
du Medef si le projet intéresse la
Guyane j'ai transmis l'ensemble des
éléments à taragovinda qui est la
présidente du manège Guyane elle a tous
les éléments en fait de l'opération si
vous voulez vous en inspirer c'est libre
de droit sans problème merci monsieur le
président
je vais vérifier si victoires jasmin a
pu se reconnecter visiblement ce n'est
pas le cas donc peut-être laisser la
parole mettant au président
merci merci Stéphane simplement monsieur
l'ortie je voulais revenir sur les je
voulais revenir sur les conclusions de
de votre travail de votre enquête
on visite beaucoup d'entreprises on est
en relation avec à peu près tout est
fédérations professionnelles et toutes
toutes disent rechercher du personnel
c'est vrai aussi et plus que tout dans
le bâtiment et dans la restauration et
l'hôtellerie
je reviens sur la restauration de
l'hôtellerie puisque vous avez parlé des
serveurs dans votre analyse
lumi qui est le syndicat professionnel
qui est présidé par Thierry Marx nous
fait on l'a reçu les gens de lumière on
les voit très couramment il y a 300000
300000 offres d'emploi 300000 et donc ça
fait partie des professionnels pour
lesquels dans les réflexions sur la loi
immigration on permettrait de pouvoir
faciliter l'arrivée de personnes du
monde entier donc il y a un paradoxe si
vous voulez entre l'attitude que vous
décrivez par votre enquête et puis la
réalité du terrain
Thierry Marx lui-même a créé une école
cuisine mode d'emploi où il recrute
indifféremment les gens n'ont pas sur
leur formation mais il les recrute pour
pour en quelques semaines les maîtres au
niveau de d'employabilité mot pas très
pas très jolie bref
on rencontre pas le sentiment que semble
d'écrire les résultats de vos de vos
enquêtes donc il y a un paradoxe
vraiment tellement énorme
les mêmes personnes ne peuvent pas ne
peuvent pas dire qu'ils veulent exclure
tel ou tel candidature alors qu'il
recherche désespérément non pas pour
leur développement mais simplement pour
pour le fonctionnement normal et il y a
beaucoup de restaurants qui qui ferment
le soir il y a beaucoup de restaurants
qui ferment deux ou trois jours par
semaine y compris dans le littoral
touristique parce qu'il ne trouve pas de
personne et donc je trouve un peu voilà
un paradoxe ce que vous avez eu des
contacts avec la profession je pense que
Thierry Marx c'est une personne d'une
ouverture d'esprit absolue et c'est
intéressant de confronter tout ça quoi
je redonne la parole à Victor jasmin et
après je la parole à la salle pour les
éléments de réponse
oui je parlais du moyen de l'éducation
nationale les critères concernant les
différents niveaux d'études au premier
du premier degré du second degré parce
qu'il y a des effectifs sous les
établissements d'outre-mer et le
problème c'est que les mêmes critères
que dans l'Hexagone existent et très
souvent il y a des manques de moyens
alors moi je pense qu'il y a auparavant
tout le temps des liés à l'idée donc
pour résoudre ce problème de
l'illettrisme il faudrait peut-être
qu'on s'attarde différemment qu'on fasse
de la pédagogie différenciée donc je
crois que c'est important et la question
des des moyens d'accueil parce que très
souvent il y a une différence également
qu'on peut noter dans les offres
d'emploi pour les originaires de nos
territoires par rapport aux hexagonaux
de la mesure quelquefois sur certains
points pour certains postes il y a des
offres de voitures pour le logement de
facilités pour mieux s'installer alors
que pour nos jeunes qui viennent qui ont
les mêmes diplômes et qui pourraient
bénéficier de ces postes et bien
quelquefois malheureusement ils ne sont
pas forcément je choisis et l'étude qui
a été faite qui nous a été présenté au
début le montre la cité pour la
restauration mais dans d'autres domaines
également et je vous souhaiterais
également pour la dgom que l'état donne
l'exemple également parce que très
souvent dans les différents postes alors
que nous constatons tous et toutes que
nos étudiants viennent dans l'Hexagone
font les grandes études de plus en plus
il réussissent brillamment je dirais que
pour certains
responsabilités dans les services de
l'État et bien ils ne sont pas visibles
des Ultramarines ne sont pas forcément
les personnes qui sont recrutés de l'eau
qui font les mêmes études que ceux qui
sont
recrutés par l'État dans ses services
donc je mets sinon j'ai beaucoup
apprécié
aussi les questionnements de Vivette
Lopez qui parlent également du handicap
qui parle de certains noms de
dispositions qui seraient intéressant de
prendre en compte merci beaucoup
pour ceux et celles qui voudraient
apporter des éléments de réponse
je souhaiterais répondre au président en
fait sur ce le point précis qui est qui
est évoqué donc d'une part on a des
évidences empiriques assez nettes qui
nous disent que la montée des
difficultés de recrutement sur le marché
du travail et plutôt un facteur qui va
diminuer les discriminations à
l'embauche
effectivement dans un contexte pénurique
ou il y a très peu de candidats par
poste il va être beaucoup plus coûteux
pour un employeur de d'être très
sélectif et de faire jouer à des
critères personnels un rôle dans le dans
le recrutement ça c'est ça c'est une
chose mais pour autant
un recruteur qui serait discriminant et
bien va être confronté à davantage de
difficultés de recrutement dans un
contexte pénurique ce que je veux dire
c'est que les discriminations par
amplifie les difficultés de recrutement
et donc de dire il y a des difficultés
donc pas de discrimination c'est une
erreur enfin logique en fait il peut y
avoir des plus il y a des
discriminations plus on peut on peut
ressentir des difficultés de recrutement
est-ce que je veux dire aussi c'est ce
qui est très important c'est que les
discriminations sont liées à des
stéréotypes des stéréotypes que nous
avons tous sur les territoires et sur
leurs habitants ces stéréotypes c'est
des raccourcis cognitifs qui peuvent se
faire de façon consciente ou non
consciente il y a une littérature très
abondante en psychologie qui sur les
biais implicites qui qui sont dont nous
sommes tous victimes et qui se font à
l'insu même de notre conscience et donc
il peut échapper effectivement à la
conscience des recruteurs de discriminer
parce qu'en fait ils font jouer un rôle
actif à des stéréotypes inconscients sur
les compétences associées à tel ou
caractéristiques personnelles et c'est
ça qui fait aussi la difficulté de la
thématique des discriminations en fait
c'est si on veut lutter activement
contre le phénomène il s'agit pas de
renforcer l'arsenal juridique il s'agit
pas de convaincre nos consciences
puisqu'en fait une bonne partie des
mécanismes se fait à l'insu même de
notre entendement de notre de nos
raisonnements nous nous sommes tous et
toutes convaincus que de ne pas être
discriminant et pourtant on peut l'être
malgré nous et c'est ça la difficulté
bien sûr du phénomène et du problème et
je pense que
par ailleurs sur sur le
la spécificité du secteur de la
restauration on a des preuves empiriques
absolument mais nombreuses considérables
pas simplement en France mais dans
l'ensemble des pays où on a fait ce type
de test dans la restauration il y a
effectivement ce qu'on appelle une
discrimination par la clientèle ou les
employeurs vont être beaucoup plus
ouvert pour des postes de
de cuisinier qui sont abrités de la
clientèle et ils vont être beaucoup plus
sélectifs pour des postes de serveurs
qui sont exposés à la clientèle et donc
il peut y avoir aussi ce type de
mécanisme dans le domaine de la
restauration et nous on a fait beaucoup
de tests sur la restauration depuis une
dizaine d'années et systématiquement ces
tests nous montrent que la restauration
n'est pas un domaine abrité du risque de
discrimination et donc il faut dans ce
secteur là comme dans les autres qu'il y
a un travail de la part des recruteurs
comme on le fait aussi dans le dans la
fonction publique comment on doit le
faire partout pour être vraiment formé
informé sur les biais de leur les biais
discriminatoire qui peuvent se faire à
leur insu afin de recruter dans
l'égalité
Madame De Palmas de la FEDOM vous avez
la parole
bonjour merci encore de cette initiative
et à laquelle nous avons été très très
heureux de contribuer je voudrais juste
apporter
quelques quelques indications sur la
manière dont la feudom madame Richard
compte s'impliquer davantage et stimuler
davantage la réflexion de ces de ces
adhérents sur cette problématique auquel
d'ailleurs personne n'est
indifférent mais donc de manière un peu
plus systématique et pratique je
voudrais
donc rappeler que on a entamé depuis
quelques temps
une nouvelle action de communication qui
ont justement pour vocation de valoriser
ce que Madame Broca s'appelait
l'aéroport
et justement de présenter des des
succès stories après ça ou simplement
des parcours qui peuvent être qui
peuvent être éclairants qui peuvent être
stimulants et qui permettent justement
euh de sortir du registre de la
caricature que l'on peut avoir de de de
vis-à-vis des territoires et de la
manière dont il dont il fonctionne et au
contraire de montrer que des choses ils
sont ils sont tout à fait possible et
que des gens ils réussissent de manière
brillante on en aura quelques exemples
dans la deuxième table ronde d'ailleurs
je pense donc voilà on a on a aussi pris
le parti de de
faire ses communications par voie de
podcast pour entrer dans des dans des
modes de communication qui sont plus
proches de ce que les jeunes ont
l'habitude de de faire et de avec lequel
ils ont l'habitude de de se renseigner
par ailleurs on s'associe on s'est
associé on s'associera le plus possible
et davantage encore à toutes les
initiatives qui sont prises en matière
de rencontre entre justement les jeunes
et les employeurs ultramarins monsieur
Chavigné a de Carrefour pour pour
l'emploi à Paris où il y a un village
outre-mer dont on fait systématiquement
la promotion on avait organisé l'année
dernière avec l'appui du ministère de
l'Outre-mer la Digital diaspora
connexion qui qui a effectivement nous a
beaucoup plus éclairé nous sur les
difficultés justement des jeunes pour
avoir accès à l'information sur les
possibilités de travailler en outre-mer
et justement où ils avaient vraiment
souligné cette cette notion de bouche à
oreille à laquelle ils étaient assez peu
familiarisés par définition lorsqu'ils
sont en outre-mer et donc
j'ai bien entendu aussi cette
problématique des stages et je pense que
là effectivement on a peut-être nous on
a une réflexion à mener à la matière
donc je ne pense pas m'avancer trop au
nom du Président en disant qu'on va on
va vraiment réfléchir à voir ce qu'on
peut faire sur le sujet
et puis
j'invite aussi
notamment madame madame d'envol Guyane à
nous signaler les les relais qu'elle
aurait à Paris parce que une des choses
qu'on voudrait faire c'est
systématiquement quand on a des
événements à caractère public des
conférences etc sur les autres mères on
aimerait pouvoir convier à ces
manifestations publiques les
associations de jeunes ultramarins qui
sont basés à Paris ou en métropole et on
en a pas nécessairement toujours la
parfaite connaissance donc voilà
n'hésitez pas à nous faire connaître vos
relais à Paris pour qu'on puisse les
associer aux événements qu'on organise
sur des problématiques économiques qui
seraient susceptibles de les intéresser
et de leur donner une information sur ce
qui se passe sur leur territoire
d'origine
et puis et puis terminez en vous disant
que au sein de la commission économique
de la FEDOM qui
de sujets parfois un peu enfin voilà qui
traite de fiscalité qui traite d'exode
charges et qui traitent des sujets dont
on traite habituellement mais la
commission économique a décidé aussi de
se saisir de ce sujet de l'emploi des
jeunes en s'interrogeant
Isabelle Richard disait il faut qu'on se
remette en question ben on
s'interrogeant sur la notion une notion
qui alors on parle toujours
d'employabilité et il y a une notion qui
a été étudiée par des universités il y a
quelques années qui est l'employeur
habilité et en fait aujourd'hui
effectivement les la proche des jeunes
vis-à-vis du travail est différente
et président de notre commission disait
récemment c'est pas eux qui s'adapteront
à nous c'est à nous de s'adapter à eux
parce que finalement l'avenir c'est eux
ici on n'est pas capable d'adapter notre
non notre approche et nos entreprises à
ce qu'ils en attendent
on risque d'aller vers des lendemains un
peu qui des chantent donc voilà donc
cette réflexion sang est entamée au sein
de notre commission économique et je
pense que je pense que ça sera porteur
de peut-être de messages un peu
différent voilà mais en tout cas sachez
qu'on est extrêmement sensible à cet à
cette à cette approche enfin à cette
dimension et voilà j'ai fait vraiment un
appel à tous les les les
ultramarins qu'on nous fasse connaître
les réseaux de jeunes ultramarins en
métropole pour que vraiment
systématiquement puisse les associer à
nos manifestations
je vous remercie
je vous remercie ces propos vont achever
cette première table ronde je remercie
nos intervenants et intervenants pour la
qualité de cet échange il y aurait
beaucoup à dire j'aurais beaucoup de
commentaires à faire et je ne ferai pas
puisque le temps nous est compté et j'ai
déjà débordé 1000 pardon cher président
d'avoir empiété sur le timing de la
seconde table ronde remercier profité
pour en remercie pour remercier
hervé-maritan et les équipes de la FEDOM
pour nous avoir aidé à construire cette
table ronde une merci de cette
contribution fort guide Président je te
laisse maintenant la parole pour la
seconde table ronde merci à toutes et à
tous merci chers collègues évidemment
mais ceci au remerciements pour les
participants à ce à cette première table
ronde avant d'entamer la seconde
simplement une information pour nos
collègues sénateurs et sénatrices
sur le réseau Demeter
2 rubriques délégations entreprises et
délégations à l'Outre-mer vous trouverez
une revue de presse qui a été préparée à
l'occasion de cette table ronde où on
retrouve des interventions de certains
des participants et ça peut nourrir
votre réflexion
voilà alors on va attaquer la deuxième
table ronde avec un impératif que je
rappelle dès maintenant qu'il faudra
avoir fini impérativement à midi puisque
il y a un déplacement de prévu pour
notre délégation et on doit retrouver un
certain nombre de nos collègues pour un
départ en Vendée et une visite
d'entreprise sur les deux jours
à suivre donc à midi on sera vraiment
obligé de conclure
cette échange alors je j'accueille en
présentiel il est déjà là Monsieur
Pascal chavignat et je saluerai je
j'espère qu'ils nous ont rejoint un
certain nombre d'autres participants qui
seront en visio donc Monsieur Pascal
chavignat c'est présenté tout à l'heure
mais je rappelle directeur des
ressources humaines du Groupe Bernard
Ayo j'ai bien h groupe familial de près
de 16000 collaborateurs
qui multiplie les initiative pour
recruter de jeunes diplômés dans les
territoires où il est implanté
madame Jeanne loyer alors est-ce qu'elle
est
[Musique]
directrice adjointe de cliniculture pour
évoquer l'initiative sur mesure réalisée
en partenariat avec la Dom l'agence
d'outre-mer pour la mobilité
madame Mitchell Malézieux fondatrice de
la plateforme retour au pays je remercie
participer en visioconférence malgré le
grand décalage horaire votre retour en
Guadeloupe madame ne fut pas facile mais
votre initiative a été couronnée de
succès et nous serons heureux d'entendre
votre point de vue
monsieur fait swall moussoul président
fondateur de Mayotte intak monsieur en
visiocover en visio conférence également
pour évoquer votre expérience de
créateur d'une entreprise d'ingénierie
informatique et de président du gentil
groupement des entreprises mahoraises
des technologies de l'information et de
la communication
alors je vais vous aider à chacun la
parole pour un propos liminaire d'une
durée de 7 minutes dans l'ordre de
présentation que je viens de faire puis
mes collègues ont sans doute des
questions pour favoriser les échanges en
vous remerciant de votre participation
et donc immédiatement je cède la parole
à Monsieur chavignat pour 7 minutes
merci monsieur le Président merci de me
donner l'opportunité donc de présenter
des initiatives que nous vous avons
prises au nom de GVH sur différents
territoires sur lesquels le groupe est
présent je commencerai par la plus
récente qui est la création d'un salon
de recrutement que nous avons appelé
avenir outremer my GBH qui s'est tenu
récemment pour créer ce salon qui est
vraiment l'initiative la plus récente et
la plus importante nous sommes partis
d'un certain nombre de constats qui ont
été évoqués lors de la première
tobleront table ronde premier constat
c'est qu'il y a effectivement un nombre
de départ de jeunes très importants
des territoires dont ils sont issus pour
poursuivre leurs études dans l'Hexagone
qu'à priori une semblerait qu'il soit
plutôt peu à revenir et qu'il
poursuivent leurs expériences
professionnelles donc leurs premières
expériences professionnelles en tout cas
dans l'Hexagone qu'à un moment ou un
autre il s'interroge sur l'opportunité
d'un retour
et qu'à ce moment là effectivement ce
qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure il y
aurait une faible visibilité donc des
opportunités professionnelles sur les
territoires troisième constat alors un
quatrième constat c'est que pour le coup
j'ai BH a des besoins de recrutement qui
sont vraiment importants alors qu'il est
si vous allez sur le site gbh.fr vous
verrez que nous avons plus de 300 postes
pour voir donc 80% concernent
l'outre-mer et tout type de poste tu
vois tous secteurs tout tout niveau tout
type de contrat etc donc des besoins
importants et enfin donc les valeurs du
groupe font que nous privilégions
l'emploi local et quand je dis nous
privilégions c'est pas exclusif
évidemment ça a été évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est dès lors que nous sommes
nous pouvons attirer des candidats de
qualité nous préférons qu'ils
proviennent de l'outre-mer mais c'est
pas un recrutement exclusif bien sûr
donc en quoi consiste pardon à venir
outre-mer à venir outre-mer c'est donc
un salon de recrutement qui s'est tenu
de début avril du 3 avril jusqu'au 27
avril dans une première version digitale
autrement dit un candidat avait la
possibilité d'accéder au site à venir
outremer.fr
et d'y trouver un certain nombre
d'informations des informations sur le
groupe des informations sur les emplois
proposés par le groupe et la possibilité
donc de visionner des vidéos de
collaborateurs qui eux-mêmes sont issus
d'outre-mer et qui témoignaient sur
leurs expériences de retour et leurs
expériences dans les postes qu'ils
occupent aujourd'hui je vous invite à
consulter ces vidéos sur les sites à
venir outre-mer parce que je crois
qu'elles éclairent sous un angle plutôt
sympa et dynamique un certain nombre de
discussions que nous avions tout à
l'heure et enfin donc un candidat avait
la possibilité de postuler sur ce site
sur les 140 non 150 offrent que nous
avions pour voir dont nous considérions
que les 150 offres en question
répondaient à des profils de d'étudiants
en fin de cursus ou de jeunes diplômés
qui étaient vraiment la cible de cette
de cet événement à venir outre-mer à
notre connaissance et la première fois
qu'un événement de cette ampleur adressé
particulièrement cette cible d'étudiants
ou de jeunes diplômés
alors donc j'ai parlé de la partie
digitale la possibilité donc de
s'informer et de recruter et de
candidater pardon en distanciel mais
nous avons ensuite animé un événement le
27 soir 27 au soir 27 avril au soir à
Paris dans un lieu vraiment adapté à un
public plutôt plutôt jeune diplômé et
nous avons reçu à cette occasion donc
130 participants qui sont venus
rencontrer les équipes de GBH pour
s'informer là aussi sur le groupe
s'informer sur les métiers du groupe
avoir des échanges avec un certain
nombre de nos collaborateurs sur les
problématiques de voilà de retour
globalement je vous avais vécu le retour
et vous avez vécu donc la recherche de
poste et vous occupez aujourd'hui des
postes importants au sein d'un groupe
important partager cette expérience avec
nous et enfin donc les équipes RH
étaient présentes pour recruter alors au
travers de cette initiative à venir
outre-mer nous avions un certain nombre
d'enjeux un premier enjeu qui est un
enjeu absolument important de notoriété
du groupe et de visibilité puisqu'on l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure la problématique
de marque employeur aujourd'hui si vous
me permettez de jargonner est absolument
capital je n'en ai plus à une époque où
il s'agit de poster une offre et puis
d'attendre tranquillement que les CV
tombent l'employeur doit se faire
connaître doit faire connaître ces
postes ces opportunités etc donc un
premier enjeu c'est en jeu là a été
plutôt bien rempli le site Internet a
été vraiment extrêmement visité le
nombre de participants à l'événement a
été important et le nombre de candidats
est également important
donc un deuxième enjeu qui était un
enjeu de fréquentation du salon et de
l'événement je l'évoquais à quelques
instants nous avons maintenant un enjeu
de recrutement et pour le coup je sais
que les premiers recrutements ont
commencé et j'espère que dans quelques
semaines dans sa capable de tirer du
point de vue des recrutements c'est
quand même un enjeu important nous
serons capables de tirer un bilan un
bilan important donc voilà ça c'est la
dernière initiative en date et qui
s'adressait à un public encore une fois
plutôt étudiant plutôt jeune diplômé
qu'il soit à l'Outre-mer ou qu'il soit
sur présence sur les territoires à côté
de ça de nos développons et j'en
conclurai par là un certain nombre
d'autres initiatives que j'ai évoquées
très rapidement tout à l'heure d'abord
il est important quand on est un groupe
implanté fortement sur les territoires
d'établir des relations solides avec
avec les écoles on a évoqué tout à
l'heure la problématique de la
qualification est parfois de
qualification insuffisante nous avons
développé aujourd'hui une fondation avec
l'université Antilles et dans le cadre
de cette fondation nous effectuons un
certain nombre d'actions dont une qui
est particulièrement visible en général
qui se déroule en octobre et novembre ou
GBH et ses collaborateurs va à la
rencontre des étudiants sur les campus
de l'université Antilles en Guadeloupe
et en Martinique pour aborder des
problématiques d'emploi à côté de ça
nous sommes également très présents avec
un certain nombre d'écoles je pense à la
Réunion en particulier avec le GC avec
l'IAE avec lesquels nous avons développé
des partenariats particulièrement
solides qui nous permet d'accueillir des
nombres vraiment conséquents de
stagiaires le lycée belpierre à la
Réunion je crois depuis 20 ans que le
partenariat existe nous avons accueilli
500 ou 600 stagiaires avec le GC nous
avons accueilli pratiquement une
soixantaine de stagiaires maintenant en
13 ans de partenariats et une
quarantaine de jeunes de l'UGC font
partie de l'entreprise où on fait partie
de l'entreprise donc l'importance pour
des groupes de développer des relations
le plus en amont possible avec les
écoles et les écoles et les universités
sont des choses donc que nous essayons
de faire et enfin un troisième vol j'ai
évoqué sur lequel j'aimerais revenir
parce que là on s'adresse on parle de
jeunes diplômés mais il y a également
donc une partie importante de jeunes qui
sont pour le coup plus éloignés de
l'emploi et pour le coup si on applique
nos critères un peu habituels de
recrutement on va clairement passer à
côté de ces populations donc nous avons
lancé un programme qui s'appelle
tremplin pour l'emploi donc c'est un
programme interne et dans lequel nous
nous conduisons un certain nombre
d'actions d'initiatives qui visent les
jeunes publics éloignés de l'emploi et
en général plutôt peut voir pas diplômé
je citerai deux exemples un à la réunion
et un en Guyane en Guyane récemment donc
nous sommes appuyés sur l'école de la
deuxième chance nous avons recruté 20
jeunes ces jeunes passent par un premier
SAS à l'école de la deuxième chance qui
en quelque sorte valeurs redonner les
fondamentaux en matière de savoir lire
et écrire enfin etc etc
ils vont commencer à effectuer un
certain nombre de stages en entreprise
passer cette période de 5 mois ils
intégrer une filiale de GBH en Guyane et
pendant une durée de pratiquement un an
en alternance nous les préparons au
métier de vendeur en grande surface et
surtout nous les préparons à passer un
diplôme et pour certains d'entre eux ce
sera sans doute le premier diplôme de
leur de leur début de vie en quelque
sorte et ce diplôme nous souhaitons nous
exigeons qu'il soit d'un niveau Bac donc
c'est vraiment en socialise on forme on
diplôme et on recrute et un jeune qui
aurait passé toutes ces étapes à la
certitude à la garantie d'un emploi en
CDI dans une structure de GBH en Guyane
nous faisons exactement le même
programme à la Réunion on nous appuyant
également sur l'école de deuxième chance
même même processus en quelque sorte
voilà merci beaucoup merci Monsieur
Chevignard et merci d'avoir respecté
strictement les 7 minutes
j'incite les prochains intervenants même
rigueur alors madame Jeanne loyer je
vous donnais la parole vous êtes
directrice générale des sociétés de
dialyse Réunion Mayotte Dakar
directrice générale des Nova et membre
permanents de la Commission de
certification des établissements de
santé de la Haute Autorité de Santé donc
on est vraiment heureux de vous entendre
je vous donne la parole
on est on n'entend pas Madame loyer
voilà très bien voilà
actuellement je suis à la Réunion pour
me situer
très heureuse de parvenir et d'être
parmi vous et effectivement c'est un
gros sujet hyper sensible en tout cas en
ce qui concerne aussi la santé mais vous
savez que la santé dans la santé nous
avons tout un tout un éventail de métier
et qui dit la santé va mal tout le reste
effectivement en découle donc là nous
étions sur une proposition sur
qu'avons-nous fait en tant qu'initiative
et perspective sur les pays d'outre-mer
j'ai un petit peu plus ouvert puisque
nous concernons nous en ce qui nous
concerne nous sommes sur la Réunion
Mayotte on a un petit peu touché les
Comores et nous travaillons nous sommes
en train de travailler sur Maurice et
bien sûr Dakar puisqu'on était en train
de s'installer sur Dakar et bientôt la
Guyane donc la vision est assez large
effectivement et concernant
le manque le manque on va dire de
d'approche
de de candidature et et gérer la
distance et les désenclavesments de tous
ces pays n'est pas évident notre survie
vient de là pourtant on est mal d'une
petite île qui est la réunion puisque
nous sommes pas en métro bien que nous
ayons aussi des cliniques en métropole
et l'idée c'était de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on allait survivre je le dis
puisque ce sont des enjeux vitaux
puisqu'on parle de la santé en général
avec un savoir-faire puisque par exemple
pour donner une idée on représente 78%
de la chirurgie à la Réunion
à Mayotte on est les seuls en tant que
privé oui parce que j'avais mis les
petits entre guillemets privés et c'est
très difficile surtant ces temps avec le
wambouchou donc vous pouvez bien
imaginer la désertification dans tous
ces pays
nous allons dû nous allons devoir ayant
ayant des établissements de santé une
vingtaine nous allons devoir pas que de
santé d'ailleurs je le répète il y a
d'autres émanations de produits on va
dire économiques et nous allons nous
devons instituer des mouvements moi
j'appellerai ça des mouvements j'ai été
aussi dans le temps j'ai été RH du
groupe puisque je suis aussi RH et il
était important de REM bénéficier de
toutes les compétences in situ ceci
étant il y en a pas puisque je rejoins
tout ce qui était dit tout à l'heure
j'ai écouté
toutes vos remarques et je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec tout ce qui était dit
malheureusement nous en souffrons et les
contextes sont pas évidents c'est
l'outre-mer oui mais comment faire il
était dans le temps je me souviens il y
a une dizaine d'années c'était assez
attractif bon c'était loin mais
l'outre-mer était attractif aujourd'hui
c'est pas le cas ce n'est plus le cas
mais en tout cas en ce qui nous concerne
puisque je travaille sur le sujet je
termine la mémoire et le le coûte le
coûte lorsqu'on me dit en Martinique il
y a 5000 départs par an etc
quand même me fait poser des questions
du coup on perd tout ce qui va être
le on va dire les la
professionnalisation des transferts de
compétences voilà c'est ça qui me gêne
et on en a plus donc ça s'en va mais ça
ne revient plus
il y a une il y a 5 ans à peu près
j'allais travailler avec la Dom
puisqu'on m'avait dit de d'essayer de
trouver des synergies pour envoyer des
infirmières et des aides-soignantes avec
la DOM
vous voulez dire qu'il partait de
Mayotte et qui partait de la Réunion ils
allaient à Paris et en métropole à
Dieppe exactement et il restait trois
ans et on les aidait avec une aide on va
dire complémentaire bien évidemment pour
la profession et pour le logement avec
une priorité de revenir sur l'île ils
étaient prioritaires pour la petite
anecdote on nous en avons eu une seule
qui est revenue sur les trois ans ce qui
prouve que les gens une fois partis sont
restés c'est aussi un exemple il faut
l'entendre aujourd'hui je travaille à
Dakar et je me suis dit que qu'est-ce
que je peux faire
il n'y a plus de de
personnel à la Réunion il y a plus de
personnels à Mayotte il y a plus de
personnel Comores il y a plus de
personnel à Maurice comment on peut
faire ou aux échelles ce que je viens
aussi des Seychelles et l'idée
heureusement l'idée extraordinaire je
vais dire c'est d'avoir plusieurs
plusieurs établissements dans plusieurs
pays et je me suis dit on va c'est pas
joli ce que je vais vous dire puisqu'on
parle d'approvisionnement je veux dire
de ressources humaines c'est pas très
beau mais je vais être un peu dans cette
synergie là et j'ai écrit j'ai demandé
au préfet à tous les préfets j'ai
demandé est-ce que on pourrait trouver
une solution sur
l'employé militaire dans le cadre
administratif qui permettrait de
recruter du personnel étranger au sein
des établissements lambda j'ai eu des
réponses une réponse d'un préfet qui m'a
dit oui on peut trouver des synergies on
peut vous accorder certaines
aides etc mais le décret de 2018 en tout
cas
l'arrêté du 11 juin 2018
là je cible par exemple infirmière
puisqu'on en a besoin de 600 les emplois
d'infirmiers ne figurent pas dans la
liste des métiers en tension
on est en 2023 on a eu le covid donc on
peut peut-être partir sur toutes ces
petites bouts des géances ou de
tractations qui font que on se dit ok on
va remuer si elle était oui ok moi je
vois oui les idées sont bonnes mais si
au départ si vous voulez les choses sont
pas mises à plat et qu'on met pas 2023
et que des petits détails comme ça nous
bloque on peut pas avancer puisque on
n'a pas l'accord on ne peut plus avancer
donc ça c'est le petit 1 que je voulais
quand même souligner donc on est en
train de faire des recherches mais
effectivement j'ai eu le document devant
les yeux et c'est quand même incroyable
on est en 2023 que qu'on me dise que les
métiers en tension tels que les
paramédicales n'est pas en tension je
veux bien mais avec ce qui s'est passé
on a eu assez de leçons avec le covid je
suis quand même
l'approche est quand même
elle est questionnante ensuite
l'échelle d'exigence pour nos pays pour
nous pour nos pays d'outre-mer sont
effectivement sont compliqués difficiles
parce que dire à quelqu'un qui a vécu en
outre-mer et lui dire bon il faut partir
on va t'aider mais bon il faut le cadre
et c'est compliqué je peux faire
l'expérience de ceux qui sont métropoles
puisque nous avons aussi des
établissements métropoles c'est vrai que
quand on se s'installe on peut aller en
trois jours avoir une inscription avoir
un immobilier etc quand on vient de
métropole c'est très compliqué on a du
mal donc là je rejoins je rejoins
Martinique je rejoins un gold la
Guadeloupe et je suis tout à fait dans
la tranche ou dans la tranche
transnationale on pourra appeler ça
comme ça on a aussi la des besoins
mettre en place
et là l'action prioritaire qui nous nous
a mis en oeuvre c'est fait ce qu'on fait
est-ce qu'on reforme pour former ou
est-ce qu'on propose des historiques
mais à court terme puisque l'histoire
n'existe plus tout à l'heure aussi
j'entendais les métiers en tension
c'était l'hôtellerie mais la santé on
est à l'identique que l'hôtellerie c'est
bien des professions avec une loi
d'immigration à revoir aussi on est dans
un paradoxe aussi je vous rejoins
monsieur le Président qui avait pris la
parole tout à l'heure c'est bien la
réalité du terrain la réalité des
terrains je vais pas dire du terrain des
terrains
et là on a on a dans nos dans nos
territoires
un manque d'approvisionnement
de formation spécifique et de gens aussi
qui veulent rester et heureusement je
rejoins aussi madame la Présidente tout
à l'heure qui parlait de peut-être d'un
mouvement nouveau sur la participation
de du de la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui oui
de l'employabilité de la Genèse
d'aujourd'hui je confirme
la durée de vie dans un pays c'est 6
mois et je les interroge parce que je
trouve ça très intéressant on appelle ça
le premier regard et je demande et
pourquoi vous partez parce qu'on a fait
le tour et on veut revoir notre périple
ah donc il faut l'entendre aussi c'est
qu'on veut plus s'enclaver on veut plus
avoir un projet professionnel fixe le
concept donc nous on s'est dit
travaillons sur une compétence fondée
sur un concept de passeport
professionnel national ou international
dans ces cas-là on va essayer de
répondre à la collectivité répondre à la
population de la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui
du vouloir bouger voilà voilà un petit
peu sur quoi on a travaillé et écoutez
c'est en train de fonctionner puisque
contrairement à
à la Suisse contrairement qui
fondamentalement sont des emplois
d'illités avec des gens au-delà 64 ans
quand même faut le savoir vous avez
plein de cliniques qui ferment plein de
sang qui ferment on survit pour
l'instant ça a l'air marcher
du coup la distance devient un enjeu la
distance de vient une petite stimulation
on va dire mais le savoir-faire derrière
il faut l'assurer et ça la compétence il
faut se débrouiller tout seul parce que
là l'aide n'est pas encore dans il y a
le logement effectivement parce que là
aussi j'ai pas entendu on assume le
logement on a su la locomotion on assume
et puis
parler la même langue là aussi c'est
encore un autre problème et quand on
voit pour la petite histoire qu'à Dakar
vous avez des bacs plus 8 de Bac + 10 et
qui sont
sans emploi et qui sont en attente et
qui correspondent totalement à nos
critères ne serait-ce pour pouvoir
décoller au moins la situation et ben on
peut pas on peut pas échanger non plus
donc ce transfert de compétences là
aussi comme il n'y a pas de contexte
légal en cours on peut pas y travailler
et pourtant nous on va s'installer par
exemple à Dakar j'emmène bien ma cellule
qui va bouger et là on est dans un
carcan aussi de nouveau donc ce carcan
peut-être trouver une modélisation un
peu plus on va dire moins
rude au moins raide et
la place de l'humain sur un mouvement
c'est pour ça que j'appelle ça le
mouvement et et puis essayer de partager
et le désenclavement pour revenir aussi
à quelqu'un qui est intervenu tout à
l'heure qui disait
le carcan publique privé où on peut tous
être ensemble et trouver des bonnes
synergie aussi on l'a vu aussi en 2000
pour le covid ou
au bout de six mois on se rend compte
que ben oui ben non il y a des gens qui
ont qui ont des blogs qui ont des sites
et on n'avait pas besoin de prendre les
trains on n'est pas besoin de faire tout
ça et je pense que là peut-être une
ouverture plus globale plus plus ouverte
avec des des moyens très simples mais
c'est un mélange de communication un
mélange de de
du savoir-faire un mélange
d'approvisionnement un mélange de gérer
l'extraordinaire parce que ça peut nous
retomber sur la tête demain et les flux
tendus comme pour l'hôtellerie nous
sommes en flux tendu il est on n'a
jamais vu ça et donc là on se pose
vraiment des questions vous avez des
services scientifiques prenez un
rendez-vous on les aurez pas et pour
revenir sur l'identifier la filière
insertion RSA je suis tout à fait
d'accord aussi je le vis à la Réunion il
est pragmatique son cheminement je
dirais qu'il est creusé pourquoi quand
je dis creuser c'est-à-dire que vous
avez les sillons on est dedans et on
aboutit effectivement vous disiez à 80%
on le vit aussi moi je trouve que là on
a un exemple c'est une c'est un exemple
à prendre pourquoi parce qu'il part d'un
départ avec un but atteint qui n'est pas
la débrouille qui est un socle commun
solide avec une employabilité certaine
puisqu'il y a une expertise au bout et
moi je pense que là dessus moi ça
m'intéresse aussi et ça je vais un petit
peu creuser moi j'aimerais bien qu'on
développe tout ça vers la santé je pense
que ça pourrait être aussi une
initiative intéressante et surtout elle
est sûre et elle donne de l'emploi et
l'emploi bien évidemment je reviens avec
tout ce que vous aviez décrit tout à
l'heure où on en a besoin et il n'est
pas servi voilà merci merci Madame loyer
je vais passer la parole à Madame
Mitchell mal aux yeux fondatrice de la
plateforme retour au pays pour qu'elle
nous parle de ce projet
je donne la parole bonjour à tous donc
oui je suis retournée en Guadeloupe en
2019 donc suite à mes études j'ai obtenu
mon master en communication digitale et
du coup j'ai décidé de rentrer
quand je suis rentrée en 2019 j'ai vécu
on va dire pas mal de mauvaises choses
c'est à dire surtout au niveau de
l'emploi en fait j'ai pas trouvé
d'emploi qui correspondait à mes
attentes à mon domaine de compétence ça
a été difficile
j'ai eu des CDD etc alors que je
recherchais véritablement un CDI dans
mon domaine
en début 2020 j'ai eu l'idée de créer la
plateforme retour au pays donc ça a
commencé par un compte Instagram qui
comptabilise aujourd'hui plus de 47.000
abonnés l'idée en fait c'était de tout
juste je voulais juste savoir s'il y
avait des gens des jeunes en tout cas
diplômés qui étaient rentrés au pays et
qui était dans le même cas que moi
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait les
difficultés à trouver un emploi
au début c'était vraiment
c'était une fin c'était un compte
Instagram c'était vraiment une idée
personnelle je cherchais pas forcément à
ce que les jeunes décident de rentrer au
pays et puis bah ça a pris de l'ampleur
naturellement j'ai j'ai eu pas mal de
demandes beaucoup de personnes qui m'ont
demandé mais comment faire pour entropie
quelles sont les choses qui qui sont
mises en place et malheureusement j'ai
jamais eu la réponse à ces questions
parce que j'ai été dans le même bateau
que que toutes ces personnes aujourd'hui
je me rends compte que j'ai un compte
Instagram qui comptabilise 47000 abonnés
je me rends compte que la demande
les demandes sont sont quasi là tous les
jours je reçois des demandes tous les
jours je reçois des mails et je me sens
dans l'incapacité de pouvoir aider
véritablement parce que ce sont des
témoignages en fait que je ressens des
témoignages ultramarins qui sont revenus
chez eux donc des expériences
significatives des personnes qui disent
qu'ils sont rentrées qui sont super
contents parce qu'ils ont trouvé un
emploi parce que ils ont pu développer
comme ils pouvaient et aussi pas mal de
témoignages qui nous disent ben voilà
moi je suis rentré au pays j'ai pas
trouvé d'opportunité professionnelle je
me je suis rentrée chez moi mais je me
sens pas chez moi beaucoup de
témoignages qui nous disent aussi que
on revient au pays avec nos diplômes on
se rend compte qu'il y a beaucoup
d'étrangers qui viennent justement aux
Antilles Guyane etc et qui eux ont des
postes qui nous qui nous reviennent
aussi de droit et qui touche des des
salaires convenables à ses postes et
nous lorsqu'on demande la même chose
nous en font du pays malheureusement en
fait bah c'est pas possible il y a
toujours 10 000 excuses pour ne pas
avoir le poste demandé etc et voilà donc
là comme je vous disais
je me sens un peu vraiment dans cette
incapacité de pouvoir aider plus que ce
que je fais déjà alors j'ai mis en place
des des rencontres j'ai organisé le
premier événement de retour au pays le
10 décembre
2022 ou un événement qui a comptabilisé
plus de 500 personnes donc sur la
Guadeloupe j'ai commencé sur ce
département parce que je suis de la
Guadeloupe
et pareil à cet événement donc c'était
l'idée c'était de pouvoir se rencontrer
de faire un peu de networking c'est un
événement qui a super bien marché la
Martinique est très demandeuse à ce
niveau la Guyane aussi m'a demandé
est-ce que ça serait possible de venir
etc mais voilà toujours cette incapacité
de pouvoir dire ben voilà voici ce qui
est mis en place voici comment trouver
un emploi etc etc donc voilà
merci vraiment merci beaucoup pour votre
témoignage et votre initiative et bravo
pour pour le succès évidemment il faut
il faut trouver des relais pour pour
vous fournir de l'information
on aparté je voyais avec le président
Artano
les gens du ministère sont plus là donc
on fera passer le message mais vraiment
on va rester en lien avec vous pour
parce que le succès de votre démarche
montre bien que c'est un souci pour les
pour les jeunes ça a été quelque chose
qu'on a évoqué pendant toute la première
table ronde et vraiment
ça serait utile que vous puissiez faire
passer des messages
pratiques et puis aussi déboucher sur
sur des résultats pour les uns les
autres en tout cas merci je passe la
parole à Monsieur faitsual moussoul qui
est président en fondateur de Mayotte
intègre dans la
créer une entreprise d'ingénierie
informatique c'est le Président je vous
passe la parole
bonjour Merci d'avoir convié à cette
table ronde donc effectivement je suis
entrepreneur je suis mort et donc j'ai
fait mes études à Mayotte que j'ai
poursuivant métropole et je suis rentré
en 2001 à Mayotte donc je connais assez
bien le parcours retour au pays avec des
ambitions voilà qui était qui était très
grande en fait au départ de la métropole
le retour effectivement était à un peu
plus difficile avec des attentes qui
étaient pas forcément tout à fait
satisfaites j'ai eu la chance par contre
quand même d'être recruté pas forcément
un poste qui me convenait pas forcément
un salaire qui me convenait et ça m'a
permis de d'être sur place et
d'envisager voilà de nouvelles
perspectives je me suis tourné vers
l'entrepreneuriat et ça a été un autre
parcours du combattant
les en tant que jeune ultra marin
effectivement quand on rentre chez soi
on a l'impression qu'on nous attend avec
nos diplômes et que et que tout nous est
ouvert et que les opportunités vont nous
être
voilà
proposer assez facilement et finalement
on arrive c'est assez compliqué non
seulement il y a un contexte qui est un
peu plus complexe parce que la réalité
des marchés qui sont restreints le
parcours d'entrepreneurs standards
en métropole mais avec les contraintes
qui sont propres à notre territoire
parfois aussi un cadre administratif qui
peut être qui peut être un peu dur ou
complexe pour des gens qui sont pas
préparés et dans notre cas on traite
dans mon cas quand j'ai commencé très
peu de structures d'accompagnement très
peu d'aide en fait pour pour avancer de
dans ce sens là donc une première
initiative qui a plutôt quand même bien
fonctionné qui était très dur
mais assez rapidement j'ai rencontré en
fait des amis des collègues
qui avaient cette volonté d'entreprendre
et qui était confronté au même
problématique donc on a décidé assez
rapidement en fait de se de s'organiser
et et de et de et de constituer
finalement ce qu'on a appelé au départ
le donc le groupement des entreprises au
reste du lycées une approche très
sectorielle concernant le numérique
c'était de se dire les problématiques
qu'on va rencontrer en tant
qu'entrepreneur dans le secteur
numérique sont à peu près les mêmes ça
serait bien qu'on partage un peu ces
problématiques entre nous qu'on parle
d'une voix commune quand il s'agira de
de d'échanger avec les institutions les
administrations et qu'on adresse un peu
nos différents enjeux la première des
choses qu'on a faites en fait ça a été
alors donc le génétique a évolué pour
devenir
Mayotte aujourd'hui un cluster un
cluster numérique donc un des premiers
sujets ça a été finalement
de travailler sur la compétence
travailler sur la sur la l'accès
à des compétences à Mayotte
le on a commencé par essayer de
on avait une très mauvaise connaissance
de la filière donc on a lancé une étude
monographique qui nous a permis de
recenser un peu mieux les les acteurs de
notre filière les profils qu'on avait
les typologies d'entreprise
euh et euh et on s'est rendu compte
effectivement on était un petit peu plus
nombreux que ce qu'on pensait on a
identifié une centaine d'acteurs
avec une filière qui est composée
essentiellement de petits acteurs des
sociétés individuelles ou des structures
de moins de 5 salariés donc traiter des
problématiques de recrutement et ainsi
de suite quand on a une petite structure
sans fonction support sans personnel
administratif et ainsi de suite c'est un
peu plus compliqué les grands groupes
ont générale en fait un service en tout
cas une organisation dédiée à cela et
donc quand il s'agit d'accompagner ces
structures là dans de la croissance
quand il faut recruter tout tout
s'appuie un peu sur le dirigeant qui qui
va un peu avec les petites mains donc on
a essayé au niveau du cluster au final
de d'apporter un peu de un peu de
soutien déjà on a recensé en fait les
besoins on s'est rendu compte que le
gros des besoins était des besoins en
fonction support donc fonctionne
administratif financière comptable
ce qui n'était pas forcément ce à quoi
on s'attendait il y a aussi des besoins
en compétence technique généralement de
haut niveau du Master 2 du Bac + 4 en
fait
voire plus et
une fois qu'on a identifié ce besoin là
on a essayé de travailler avec les
pouvoirs publics Pôle emploi et ainsi de
suite pour pour voir comment on pouvait
les adresser
on s'est rendu compte que un certain
nombre de dispositifs étaient déjà en
place en fait sur le territoire mais peu
ou mal connu en fait des dirigeants donc
ça a permis déjà de faire l'inventaire
de ce qui était de ce qui était mis en
place on a des dispositifs à l'emploi
les dispositifs de de d'accompagnement à
la mise en place de de cette solution
d'alternance et ainsi de suite
effectivement nos dirigeants avaient du
mal en fait soit on ne connaissait pas
du tout c'est ces dispositifs là où
avaient du mal en fait à les mobiliser
donc un premier travail qui est toujours
en cours d'ailleurs
des outils et une approche on va dire
très pragmatique je le disais tout à
l'heure on parle d'une centaine
d'entreprises
ce qui est intéressant en fait sur les
territoires
en tout cas plus pour Mayotte moins pour
les autres territoires ça reste une
petite île donc quand on parle de
filière quand on parle de secteur le
on parle même plus en pourcentage on
parle de 50 personnes 100 personnes les
besoins sont quantifiables en fait on
connaît les individus qui veulent qui
veulent recruter donc c'est assez facile
d'adresser très directement avec
beaucoup de comités les besoins de
recrutement les difficultés des uns et
des autres je pense que des fois on a on
a un discours à beaucoup de distance
avec beaucoup de statistiques beaucoup
de % j'ai ainsi de suite et et ça casse
un peu en fait
[Musique]
stagilité qu'on pourrait avoir en fait
pour pouvoir adresser ses besoins là
le donc on a identifié des besoins qui
étaient des besoins un peu immédiat les
difficultés de rencontrer les
entrepreneurs on va dire sur le moment
et puis on les a sollicités aussi au
travers de de nouvelles études sur les
perspectives d'évolution de la filière
n'importe qui de recruter leurs
intentions
qui s'avère qu'on est sur une filière en
croissance
il y a plus de 60% alors je vais en
pourcentage on parle plus de la moitié
en tout cas des des personnes qu'on a
fondé qui prévoit de recruter donc qui
ont confiance en l'avenir qui prévoit de
de développer leur activité
donc c'est plutôt intéressant et on a
identifié plus ou moins le le type de
besoin en tout cas le type de profil qui
était attendu de leur part
on a une des difficultés qui nous a été
remontées par ces par ces personnes
c'était que effectivement on avait un
problème d'attractivité sur le
territoire en ce moment on parle
beaucoup de Mayotte sur les médias
nationaux pas forcément sur les bonnes
choses moi je peux vous dire que la
série récemment on a des entreprises qui
ont perdu finalement des profils qui se
positionnaient sur le territoire parce
qu'ils disent bon ben on va on va
peut-être attendre des moments meilleurs
pour venir on rencontre alors je je
rejoins et j'adhère à peu près toutes
les difficultés qui ont été entre les
problématiques qui ont été listées tout
à l'heure c'est-à-dire de la se loger
les difficultés voilà avec on va dire
[Musique]
un côté un petit peu plus exercéé je
pense à Mayotte que pour d'autres
territoires il y a beaucoup de logements
qui se créent en ce moment à Mayotte
mais c'est beaucoup le logement sociaux
pas du logement intermédiaire donc pas
forcément accessible à au profil qu'on
contre cruauté on a effectivement des
tarifs des salaires qui sont des prix
qui sont qui sont qui sont très élevés
un problème de mobilité sur le
territoire donc en fait bon tout ça est
présent
nous à notre ex on s'était dit on ne
pourra pas adresser en tant que en tant
que cluster toutes les problématiques
qui sont plutôt des prérogatives des
pouvoirs publics mais ça ne nous empêche
pas de travailler sur l'attractivité de
notre filière donc par du networking par
deux événements plutôt positifs on a
fait un travail aussi pour essayer
d'identifier très précisément et de
mettre en valeur en fait certains atouts
du territoire j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure effectivement qu'on pouvait
avoir des carrières très atypiques un
accès à la responsabilité beaucoup plus
rapide à Mayotte on a vu beaucoup de
jeunes en fait qui se demandaient qui
hésitaient à venir sur nos territoires
parce qu'ils avaient l'impression que
impacterait leur carrière
après une expérience sur le territoire
peut-être que c'est un peu moins
employable par la suite donc
casser un peu ces idées reçues
expliquées qu'au contraire généralement
une expérience dans les territoires
marins les plus tôt accélératrice
on a des retours d'expérience d'ailleurs
de jeunes qui sont qui sont venus qui
sont restés à Mayotte trois quatre cinq
ans et qui en repartant parce qu'ils ont
occuper un peu de responsable adjoint
directeur et
parfois qu'ils ont pris sur le tas
pouvaient prétendre finalement à
y compris dans des grands groupes à
l'extérieur
donc en tout cas une expérience très
formatrice
et c'est un peu tous ces aspects qu'on
travaille donc
le deuxième volet c'est que on est alors
nous ici on pense que c'est peut-être le
cas ailleurs aussi on est sur des
métiers en tension alors tous les
secteurs sont en tension la santé le BTP
l'hôtellerie le numérique aussi
nous ici on voit on est on est aussi un
peu en concurrence avec le secteur
public le secteur public est très
demandeur de de compétences recrute
beaucoup donc quand on lance des
campagnes de recrutement les profils en
fait se positionnent sur les métiers
mais effectivement
avec des propositions de de d'emploi qui
sont souvent indexés
et des avantages en fait que que les
entreprises privées ont du mal en fait à
proposer ces profils là s'orientent
finalement vers des postes dans la
fonction publique ou
qu'elle soit d'État au territorial et et
ça rend la chose encore plus dure en
fait pour les entreprises donc les
petites en particulier à Mayotte donc un
vrai sujet on l'a évoqué ici
dans plusieurs voilà dans à plusieurs
occasions c'est trouver des voir comment
on pouvait trouver des solutions c'est
assez difficile de se battre contre ça
on a travaillé aussi sur le volet
attractivité de la filière c'était faire
en sorte effectivement que quand on
vient travailler dans le numérique à
Mayotte on se retrouve totalement
on va dire déconnecté d'une certaine
réalité
donc c'est travailler sur des sur des
établissements donc des technopoles sur
les infrastructures la qualité de la
connexion internet on a voilà on a des
on a des profils quand ils veulent à
Mayotte ils veulent pas se retrouver
dans des conditions
on va dire moins confortable de travail
que s'ils allaient dans d'autres
territoires
Mayotte a une particularité aussi dans
l'océan Indien avec la Réunion c'est que
la Réunion est beaucoup plus attractive
que Mayotte avec un niveau
d'infrastructure donc on a beaucoup de
profils qui même s'ils ont envie de
venir dans la région vont préférer
s'orienter vers la réunion que de venir
vers Mayotte et parfois pour certaines
entreprises qui sont à la fois à la
Réunion et à Mayotte c'est assez
difficile de dire à des gens qui sont à
la Réunion venez à Mayotte donc tous ces
problématiques là il faut il faut
réussir à les adresser il faut réussir à
créer un certain équilibre
mais se développe donc il y a les enfin
j'ai envie de dire que le le la qualité
des infrastructures la qualité de
l'offre se développe mais elle va pas
assez vite en tout cas donc monsieur
merci pour pour ce premier avis donc je
vais devoir passer la parole à la salle
on reviendra sur vos sur vos
informations en tout cas merci de de ce
premier propos
peut-être Michel Calmette sur la partie
perspective pour l'emploi
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues mesdames messieurs
effectivement je tiens tout d'abord
remercier les différents intervenants
pour la qualité et la diversité des
actions qui sortaient dansaient qui
montrent bien qu'il se passe
effectivement dans les territoires et
départements d'outre-mer
à un certain nombre de choses et de
nombreuses initiatives qui sont mises en
oeuvre tendante à apporter des réponses
aux problèmes qui nous occupent
aujourd'hui sur cette question de
l'insertion
de la population dans les métiers dans
l'emploi et effectivement du
développement des territoires
d'outre-mer alors à Monsieur mousson qui
intervenait à l'instant je voulais lui
demander à travaillant dans le domaine
de latex si la question des réseaux de
fibres étaient suffisants à Mayotte pour
pouvoir remettre le développement de ces
usages de ces usages en quelque sorte et
puis s'il existait sur le sur le à
Mayotte suffisamment de formation
adaptée pour répondre aux besoins de des
acteurs économiques que vous avez dansé
qui sont regroupés effectivement
sur
sur place et est-ce que les des
formations elles répondent aux besoins
des de l'économie locale en quelque
sorte et faut-il repenser ou actualiser
cette formation en lien avec des
entreprises qui sont sur place
madame malicieux qui a évoqué son
initiative en Guadeloupe je voulais lui
demander d'abord si elle pouvait
effectivement vivre de cette activité de
plateforme qui a été mise en avant ou
c'était une initiative qui n'était pas
un but professionnel et s'il était
possible donc de pouvoir développer un
certain nombre d'outils pour permettre
le retour au pays de
d'un atome de jeunes
et comment faire pour tout au long de la
vie accompagner les parcours
professionnels entre la métropole et
l'outre-mer
et puis
monsieur Chavignon et Madame loyer qui
ont évoqué les initiatives alors
chavignat le président de la République
va réunir lundi à Versailles le sommet
de choses France pour attirer un centre
d'investisseurs
étrangers en France ne faudrait-il pas
qu'il y ait peut-être des initiatives de
communication plus significative qui
soit faite pour attirer les
investisseurs dans les
outre-mer en particulier est-ce que vous
pensez que les entreprises et nous en
visiterons une cet après-midi en Vendée
le groupe brillant qui a dans le domaine
de la construction métallique des
implantations en outre-mer ne
faudrait-il pas sensibiliser peut-être
un peu plus d'entreprises françaises à
l'idée que d'avoir dans leur action des
implantations en outre-mer peuvent
permettre à la fois de peut-être de
répondre à des besoins d'emploi en
termes de capacité à mobiliser
ou de mobilité de
l'ultramarin qui sont des produits
d'emploi et qui pourraient au sein de
groupe pouvoir venir en France retourner
en outre-mer revenir dans l'Hexagone
pardon il retourneurs d'outre-mer le cas
échéant est-ce qu'on peut envisager des
initiatives comme cela effectivement les
mêmes questions pour Madame loyer et
de manière plus générale est-ce que il
faut qu'on encourage
le départ en formation dans l'Hexagone
ou est-ce qu'il vous paraît plus
important peut-être d'essayer de
développer
le nombre de formations dans les
différents outre-mer permettant de
garder véritablement sur place de ne pas
inciter au départ parce que tout à
l'heure j'étais marqué par le fait que
sur l'initiative menée à Dieppe
finalement il y avait très peu de
retours les autres mères ça pose
question quant à la délocalisation de du
site de formation et le fait que s'il y
a pas de retour les outre-mer comment
peut-on faire
merci chers collègues des questions pour
chacun du coup je refais le tour pour
vous permettre
d'y répondre monsieur chavignat
je suis merci monsieur le Président je
sénateur sur le départ ou ou plutôt le
développement local de qualifications ce
qui est certain mais ça déjà été dit par
un certain nombre d'interlocuteurs
nous il y a sans aucun doute une grande
inadéquation en tout cas partiel entre
l'offre de formation locale et les
besoins des entreprises on sait déjà été
évoqué un certain nombre de fois donc
j'y reviendrai pas et et une initiative
qui consisterait à coordonner donc une
espèce de vision un peu projective des
besoins et des entreprises et de la
possibilité d'adapter donc les filières
de formation serait sans aucun doute un
plus
pour vous donner un exemple très concret
nous nous avons et nous sommes pas les
seuls GIR tous les acteurs de la grande
distribution ont des besoins importants
sur les métiers de bouche et je prendrai
l'exemple des bouchers on a mis en place
grâce à un centre d'opérateurs donc des
formations extrêmement intéressantes
mais nous sommes obligés d'aller faire
la formation en France métropolitaine
nous envoyons nos futurs boucher en
France pour se former parce que nous
n'avons pas l'infrastructure locale ou
la qualification locale
permettant de former nos bouchés
localement je parle de la Martinique
mais à mon avis le sujet est le même en
Guyane ou ailleurs donc ce qui enfin ce
qui est quand même aberrant de de mon
point de vue donc
je suis pas persuadé que la question du
départ soit soit le problème je veux
dire quand vous entendez ce qu'il y a un
certain nombre de jeunes qui s'exprime
sur l'expérience de formation qu'il
vivent à l'extérieur ils vont vous
parler a Fortius sur les études
supérieures ils vont vous dire on est
allé faire des stages à Hong Kong à
Lisbonne à Londres enfin j'en passe et
des meilleurs et je pense que nos
territoires s'enrichissent de ce type de
parcours donc un jeune qui a quitté le
territoire qui a fait des études
supérieures ou pas et qui ensuite par le
biais des différentes études est allé
faire des stages à l'international je
pense qu'on s'enrichit véritablement de
ce type de parcours donc pour moi c'est
pas le problème du départ c'est
effectivement comment est-ce qu'on rend
alors si il peut y avoir quand même un
certain nombre de problèmes avec le
départ bien sûr mais comment est-ce
qu'on rend les dès lors que je
m'interroge sur l'opportunité de venir
ou de revenir comment est-ce que je
rends visible un certain nombre d'offres
et qui soit évidemment les plus
attractifs possible même si j'ai bien
conscience que quand je dis ça je parle
du point de vue d'un groupe de 16000
collaborateurs et non pas de petites
entreprises de quelques de quelques
salariés
voilà merci Monsieur et Madame loyer si
vous voulez répondre aux questions du
sénateur qui a levé
on n'a pas le micro madame
oui merci
de me donner la parole effectivement
je l'avais dit en tout début de mon
discours on a bénéficié aujourd'hui d'un
système qui est plus ou moins on va dire
pérenne dans le temps pour assouvir nos
besoins en professionnel tout confondu
attention bien que nous ayons plus de
3000 personnes en santé et tout ce qui
est autour puisque dans la santé vous
avez l'hygiène vous avez la restauration
vous avez la blanchisserie etc et
effectivement peut-être que la facilité
de se dire pour l'histoire on a une
petite île la Réunion et du coup c'est
la Réunion qui est en train d'aller
ailleurs parce que à un moment donné on
peut s'étendre parce que on est on va
dire on a un modèle on va se faire
labelliser et ça marche et pourtant ce
sont des pays quand même assez compliqué
je répète Dakar Seychelles
Mayotte Maurice etc
mais cette diversité nous permet
justement de faire bouger les lignes
avec l'humain et j'ai l'impression que
là on va requêter les besoins et les
besoins vont asservir les formations
alors pour revenir sur le sujet tout à
l'heure sur l'encouragement des départs
oui on encourage les départs parce que
c'est maintenant que ça marche par
exemple on a instauré un pont aérien
entre tous ces différents pays que nous
avons avec les établissements et là ça
permet nous de caler le manque mais ça
ne suffit pas bien évidemment toutes ces
métiers en tension on ne revient pas de
là-dessus
mais on ne peut pas les former sur place
parce que par exemple vous donniez
l'idée de moi je peux vous donner par
exemple l'idée d'anesthésie ou de blocs
opératoire on ne peut pas ouvrir une
école que pour par exemple 5 ou 10
formations de blocs opératoire donc ils
sont obligés de partir en métropole
partir en métropole c'est partir 2 3
mois ça coûte cher etc donc là dessus il
y a transformation terrain mais
maintenant c'est obligatoire donc là
dessus il faut aussi réfléchir et le
développement lui-même sur le besoin
d'entreprise tout à l'heure sur la
question monsieur le Président des
besoins locaux adaptés à des filières de
formation oui moi en tout cas j'ai une
filière qui s'appelle ENOVA je me répète
et qui existe depuis 10 ans pour tout le
groupe et qui d'ailleurs va au-delà du
groupe puisqu'on travaille aussi avec du
public et des associatifs on sent bien
que l'émulation d'échange de ces divers
fonctionnement passe bien avec la
spécificité caliopie etc on est obligé
de se mettre dans les rails aussi mais
on ne peut faire que certains diplômes
alors j'ai beaucoup de chance puisque je
suis aussi à l'Université de la Réunion
je suis dans le conseil d'administration
donc je peux impulser mais faut pas
oublier que c'est public donc du coup on
a pu diverger faire quelques dus donc
maintenant on a plus besoin d'aller en
France en métropole pardon pour faire le
du dialyse des qualités ou des cuisines
des Huawei il y a tout ça effectivement
c'est à réfléchir mais pour certains
métiers on ne peut pas tout faire à la
Réunion si certains mais je reviens sur
monsieur felçois qui disait pour Mayotte
je suis aussi à Mayotte j'ai presque 300
personnes sur Mayotte
c'est très difficile en plus vous savez
que la sécurité tout le monde parle il y
a plus personne qui veut rester là aussi
comment peut-on jouer et pourtant les
postes sont ouverts effectivement
beaucoup d'opportunités pour des jeunes
donc cadran de cadre d'émergence
et là la simulation qu'est-ce qu'on peut
mettre en place donc du coup on prend
les gens de la Réunion on est en train
de travailler avec le Mozambique ce
point aérien doit être réfléchissant
réfléchi et ça peut fonctionner mais ça
a un coût un coup parce qu'on doit payer
le billet on doit payer le logement doit
payer les voitures donc c'est un coup
mais pour l'instant ça nous permet de ne
pas fermer c'est important ce que je dis
là on est dans un initiative vitale où
ça nous permet par rapport à d'autres
confrères qui aujourd'hui à Lille ou
ailleurs me disent on manque on manque
de gens et on ferme des ailes quand même
on ferme des ailes dans les cliniques
aussi donc ça il faut l'entendre aussi
merci Madame mal aux yeux on revient
vers vous donc les questions du du
sénateur canevé
de la plateforme je ne vis pas cette
place de cette plateforme j'ai une
activité à côté et justement mon
objectif sur le long terme c'est de
pouvoir en vivre
moi l'idée ça aurait été de pouvoir
créer un package on va dire de retour au
pays c'est à dire dans ce package avoir
le logement l'emploi qui va avec etc et
de pouvoir offrir ça directement à ce
jeune diplômé qui souhaite revenir sur
son territoire mais moi l'idée c'est
enfin depuis la création là ça va faire
trois ans que que la plateforme en tout
cas que le compte Instagram existe j'ai
créé le site internet avec mes propres
moyens
au mois de décembre justement
l'idée ça aurait été d'obtenir des aides
en tout cas un réel accompagnement sur
ce sur ce projet parce que depuis trois
ans de création bah je suis toute seule
je suis toute seule et j'aimerais bien
avoir un accompagnement et une équipe
pour pouvoir mettre plus de choses en
place en tout cas pour nos jeunes
ultramarins qui décident de revenir chez
eux
merci c'est très clair de comme
description du besoin donc on va on
reviendra vers vous or réunion
monsieur mossoun si vous voulez
répondre aussi aux questionnements du
sénateur
donc concernant la qualité des réseaux à
Mayotte elle s'est beaucoup améliorée
ces derniers temps mais elle est encore
loin d'être au niveau de ce qu'on va
retrouver au niveau national voire à la
Réunion voisine actuellement le réseau
Mayotte c'est essentiellement des accès
à DSL donc c'est ça peut être alors ça
permet de faire beaucoup de choses mais
c'est encore problématique pour
certaines activités j'imagine pour la
santé certains établissements qui
peuvent être dans le sud de Lille qui
voilà qui n'ont pas d'internet on va
dire garanti et sécurisé ceci étant il y
a une démarche en fait de il y a un
projet de déploiement et de
généralisation de la fibre qui est
portée par le département qui est en
cours qui devrait
la consultation est en cours donc on
attend à ce que les opérateurs déploient
ces réseaux dans les années qui viennent
donc d'ici 2024 en tout cas 2025 au plus
tard
donc ça changera beaucoup de choses et
le déploiement de la 5G aussi au moins
dans certains voilà dans certaines
d'activités pour avoir ce bon niveau de
connectivité donc qui est important
aussi pour traiter les autres enjeux de
formation et ainsi de suite ou de
nouveaux modes de travail
télétravail et ainsi de suite
pour ce qui est de la formation
c'est assez jeune sur le territoire donc
on a qu'une seule université on a
quelques établissements
quelques BTS en fait qui sont qui sont
mis en place donc une formation qui
s'arrête essentiellement au Bac +2 et
pas sur toutes les spécialités on était
en manque de de formation
on va dire un niveau bac + 4 il y a
quelques initiatives très on va dire
très ciblées qui qui ont été lancés
récemment elles sont plutôt
intéressantes
c'est pas suffisant pour pour
on va y répondre à tous les besoins de
la filière et puis il faut distinguer
deux types de formation la première qui
va concerner on va dire des jeunes en
formation pour lesquels effectivement
c'est pas forcément
inintéressant de quitter le territoire
pour aller acquérir un diplôme puis la
formation continue on est sur un secteur
d'activité ou les compétences doivent
être actualisées régulièrement et ça ça
peut être un frein aussi au recrutement
pour certains de se dire
qu'effectivement en venant à Mayotte ben
je vais pas aussi facilement qu'en
métropole ou qu'ailleurs pouvoir
continuer à me former ou à me
spécialiser sur sur certains métiers
donc des initiatives il y a eu des
initiatives pour que cette problématique
là puisse être été à l'échelle régionale
et c'était intéressant aussi pour nous
de voir dans certains cas
des collaborateurs ou des partenaires
et aller à la Réunion à Maurice pourquoi
pas dans certains pays d'Afrique pour
pour compléter de la formation sur des
périodes assez courtes on est à deux
heures de l'Afrique de l'Est on a deux
heures de la Réunion
il y a des destinations qui sont
peut-être plus facile que d'autres mais
c'est quand même plus facile ça serait
ça serait beaucoup plus facile de mettre
en oeuvre des programmes
dans dans ces régions là plutôt qu'un
parcours où il faut aller très loin et
être absent finalement du territoire
pendant une longue durée pour pouvoir
acquérir des qualifications
merci pour ces précisions alors on va
voir les dernières questions donc chers
collègues finira Horse et puis le
président Artano donc allez-y merci
président sera pas longue ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Pascal chavignat le
groupe Bernard rayotte est implanté sur
plusieurs secteurs dans mon territoire
donc de l'automobile à la grande
distribution et récemment le groupe a
racheté notre seul distillerie situé à
Saint-Laurent du Maroni j'aimerais
connaître le pourcentage de guyanais
embauché par le groupe dans les
différents secteurs en Guyane merci
alors on va on va prendre les questions
du président Artano en même temps comme
ça on fera des réponses globales pour
terminer merci président juste un
commentaire et puis une réflexion
puisqu'on est sur la table ronde
évolution et perspective quand j'entends
notamment la l'initiative qui a été
prise à la Guadeloupe en Guadeloupe et à
Mayotte ça interpelle quand même le
président collectivité que j'ai été sur
l'absence ou la coordination ou la prise
en considération par les politiques
locaux je le dis de manière tout à fait
objective et factuelle sur le changement
de paradigme qui doit opérer sur nos
territoires respectifs oui je parle
également de mon territoire bien
évidemment
on a quand même le sentiment que les
acteurs ne sont pas coordonnés pour
répondre à aux enjeux que vous décrivez
au contrainte auxquelles vous avez été
confronté sur vos territoires et à un
moment donné effectivement la question
de la coordination se pose me
semble-t-il et j'aimerais
j'aimerais que vous me donniez votre
regard puisqu'on est là sur les
perspectives parce que si on fait pas
preuve d'innovation je pense que vous
l'avez dit monsieur chavignat je pense
qu'on n'arrivera pas à pousser les murs
et les problèmes se répéteront de
génération en génération
merci on reprend le tour de table si
vous voulez monsieur chavignat pour
répondre à notre collègue et puis
ensuite chacun
merci monsieur le Président alors
qu'il y aurait donc une question
évidemment sensible non alors pour être
pour être tout à fait clair une très
grande majorité de nos collaborateurs
sont recrutés localement et pour
différentes raisons la première donc il
y a une question d'attractivité du
territoire et la Guyane et je le
regrette mais la Guyane est un
territoire aujourd'hui qui a qui a du
mal à tirer donc dans une superficie de
retour pays j'imagine que là aussi c'est
pas nécessairement le territoire sur
lequel on a le plus de succès c'est un
premier point deuxième point enfin il
faut se dire les choses de manière
extrêmement pragmatique faire venir un
candidat de l'extérieur c'est quelque
chose qui coûte cher ça coûte cher à
l'entreprise ça coûte cher aux candidat
et c'est une vraie prise de risque à la
fois pour le candidat et à la fois pour
l'entreprise donc dans toute la mesure
du possible l'entreprise et croyez-moi
je enfin ça fait partie mes discussions
quotidiennes avec avec la famille Ayotte
on doit privilégier autant que faire ce
peu le recrutement local et c'est le cas
c'est vraiment le cas en Guyane on doit
également s'assurer de développer des
compétences locales ce qu'on fait j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure une initiative en
Guyane vis-à-vis de jeunes qui sont
plutôt éloignés de l'emploi ce qu'on
fait également pour la partie anti sur
la distribution où on a des formations
on a mis en oeuvre des formations qu'on
a fait venir du Métropole pour le coup
parce qu'elles sont particulièrement
reconnues et qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui de former nos chefs de
rayons on recrute maintenant localement
tous les ans 40 à 50 chefs de rayon qui
sont les premiers niveaux d'encadrement
dans la grande distribution qui permet
de grande carrière donc c'est vraiment
nous assurer qu'on recrute localement
nos cadres dans la grande distribution
pour nous donner que que cet exemple là
ce Président je suis complètement
d'accord avec vous ce que vous dites
quand à la coordination des acteurs
alors je reviens sur ce qui était dit
par mon collègue de Mayotte c'est vrai
que l'avantage nos territoires la taille
est-elle qu'on a un accès assez simple à
des interlocuteurs de très bons niveaux
et alors évidemment c'est encore plus
simple quand on est DRH de GVH c'est
clair mais pour le coup on arrive à
monter des opérations en coordination
avec un certain nombre d'acteurs j'ai
évoqué Pôle Emploi tout à l'heure on
travaille en très très étroite
collaboration avec Pôle soit en Guyane
par exemple en Martinique et à la
Réunion en particulier mais il devrait y
avoir effectivement une coordination
bien plus importante des différents
acteurs je voudrais revenir sur un point
qui a été très rapidement évoqué et à
mon sens c'est quand même une clé à aux
questions qu'on se pose aujourd'hui du
retour de jeunes diplômés dans le cas de
l'initiative que j'ai évoquée tout à
l'heure lorsqu'on a monté le salon à
venir outre-mer on sait on s'est dit
mais finalement
les universités et les écoles doivent
savoir où vont leurs étudiants dès lors
qu'ils quittent les territoires et
j'étais surpris s'était dit par une
intervenante tout à l'heure que en fait
il y a enfin il y a sans aucun doute
énormément de statistiques mais
globalement personne n'y accepte donc si
je veux envoyer un message qu'un mail à
une certaine communauté pour dire nous
avons des offres à pourvoir aujourd'hui
alors je comprends qu'il est
problématiques rgpd etc mais aujourd'hui
à ma connaissance très peu d'écoles ont
un suivi ouvrez les guillemets un peu
longitudinales de leur de leur de leur
corps et ce qui nous rend donc enfin ça
rend la tâche difficile que de leur
communiquer les offres qui sont
disponibles et Dieu sait s'il y en a
pour le groupe et pour bien d'autres
acteurs également
merci Madame loyer sur ces mêmes sujets
pour
pour conclure je vous rejoins
je sais pas trop si je vais m'exprimer
parce que je travaille ça fait je
connais bien le système puisque je suis
sur Mayotte je veux parler surtout sur
Mayotte là où on est en souffrance la
Réunion on va dire ça peut aller on a
plus de 600 personnes
le turn-over peut-être que c'est le
turn-over pour pour le vivre puisque je
suis à maillot depuis 2010 pour le vivre
peut-être que dans ces différentes
instances administratives on parlait des
cours de natures acteurs des différentes
instances administratives sont
bloquantes dans quel sens dans le sens
que ça tourne tellement tous les deux
ans et demi si vous voulez il faut tout
recommencer il faut tout réexpliquer
en plus aujourd'hui pour mon collègue
qui était à Mayotte aussi aujourd'hui il
y a que mon boucs chez vous le reste
c'est pas une priorité donc si vous
voulez c'est un peu inquiétant
effectivement il faut être tenace je
vous dis pas le reste parce que on vit
des moments mais plus que difficiles que
ce soit financier ou que ce soit avec
des autorisations ou des aides on est en
on est en survie on en reparlera moi je
veux bien parler avec quelqu'un après
mais c'est très très grave ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui donc est-ce que c'est
un manque justement de ciblage ou c'est
ou c'est un débordement parce qu'il y a
plutôt la sécurité qui est en jeu il y a
une histoire politique sociale on va
dire populaire et et
parti prenante mais en tout cas tout est
en arrêt en tout cas moi je peux dire
que tout est en arrêt il faut vraiment
se battre pour y arriver voilà ce que je
voudrais dire
merci
Madame m'a les yeux peut-être pour
l'aspect de coordination locale
[Musique]
je trouve qu'il n'y a pas de soutien
voire en tout cas très peu de soutien
sur place de manière locale donc quand
on parle des politiques locales
je comme je vous ai dit j'ai organisé
mon premier événement le 10 décembre
par mes propres moyens donc j'ai
vraiment tout mis en place et tout mis
en oeuvre pour que pour que ça puisse
être une réussite et au niveau au niveau
du soutien j'ai eu j'ai eu quelques
partenaires qui ont été là mais moi je
parle plus en termes de politique locale
je ne me sens du tout pas soutenue donc
voilà
oui on a bien ressenti ça donc on en
reparlera si vous voulez comme je l'ai
dit
hors réunion
ultérieurement peut-être monsieur
mousson pour un dernier propos
oui concernant la coordination donc nous
alors il y en a encore pas assez par
contre il y a une différence entre ce
qu'on vit aujourd'hui et ce qu'on vivait
il y a 4-5 ans typiquement on a les
services du Gard par exemple qui ont
fait en sorte en fait que les
différentes services de l'État qui
seraient qui était en gestion de ces
problématiques
[Musique]
ce coordonne déjà entre eux et et sache
adressée en tout cas notre filière donc
on a vu quelques échanges effectivement
on a vu on a vu poindre des solutions
sur les différents aspects GPC et ainsi
de suite la difficulté qu'on va
rencontrer nous c'est que on passe par
le cluster pour pour centraliser un peu
les remontées de
des adhérents de la filière entre les
membres de la filière mais on est
nous-mêmes un peu sous cette affaire je
veux dire ça comme ça et donc parfois on
a du mal à adresser tous les sujets
donc on a plutôt une difficulté
d'organisation
et parfois on n'est pas spécialement
soutenu à la hauteur qui qui serait qui
serait souhaitable en moyen pour qu'on
puisse nous doter en fait des ressources
qui nous permettent de traiter ces
sujets là correctement donc
voilà ce que je pourrais en dire
aujourd'hui
merci ben écoutez je vois pas d'autres
questions
pas d'autres questions donc on va on va
conclure maintenant en vous remerciant
évidemment on est complètement dans les
temps
je me réjouis bien sûr de de ces
échanges remercier le président Artano
d'avoir permis que nos deux délégations
travaillent sur ce sujet important de
l'emploi de l'attractivité
de la formation c'est un sujet qui
touche les plus jeunes bien sûr pas que
mais en particulier les plus jeunes et
pour les territoires dont nous parlons
c'est un sujet puisqu'il y a une
jeunesse nombreuse
dynamique qui souhaitent évidemment
bâtir un avenir
social
intéressant donc je pense que nos
échanges étaient très pertinents et très
positif
il y aura une publication de nos de nos
échanges dans les semaines à venir et je
vous indique d'ailleurs que la
délégation d'entreprise examinera son
rapport formation compétences et
attractivité le 29 juin chez Michel
canevedo donc voilà vous aurez
l'opportunité d'en prendre connaissance
ni intégrera les éléments ce matin qui
concourent à notre réflexion voilà
écoutez merci beaucoup
des remerciements particuliers à nos
amis d'outre-mer qui ont fait l'effort
de nous joindre je pense assez tôt pour
certains d'entre eux et donc je vous
souhaite à tous une bonne journée et
comme on l'a dit on reviendra vers les
uns ou les autres pour
un suivi efficace de cette réunion
matinale merci bonne journée